[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
day one of the Grantchester finals here
in London for if the great kings of
chess came to do battle with the title
of GCT champion on the line the game
between Levon Aronian and ding Lorraine
fizzled quickly but it was an epic
struggle between world champion Magnus
Carlsen and Maxim Bachelor Grob and a
rich night off that ended in a draw the
world's best are back for what could be
a pivotal game of classical chess day
two of exciting action coming up next
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to day two of
the grand chess to a finals here in
London we're standing in front of the
Royal Artillery memorial dedicated to
those brave soldiers who sacrificed
their lives in World War one and World
War two well a great war is brewing on
the chessboard right now as four of the
strongest and mightiest soldiers in all
of chess do battle in the classical
portion of the event and to call all the
action we're going to dug to the studio
with Jennifer
Peter Thank You Marlies welcome
everybody to our day-to coverage of the
Grantchester finals i'm jennifer Sahadi
and i'm here with Peter Svidler and we
have a lot of great chess in store for
you today welcome everyone and yeah the
talking points about yesterday of course
will will always be the game between
Magnussen MBL one of the more exciting
Sicilians you'll see all year and we're
definitely hoping today will bring
something something along the same lines
but there's also the second match which
which which we shouldn't be forgetting
and there's there's plenty to talk about
there as well and today's game I feel
should be a lot more interesting than
the one ending there and played
yesterday I'm gonna bet with yes
although that final was kind of
interesting but let's take a look ahead
what we have so far in this competition
we do have two draws but very different
drawers as you mentioned Peter but here
it is Magnus and Maxime at a standstill
the bond and ding marin also with one
draw in the bag that means today they
reverse colors for their second
classical game but this tournament is
about rather this match series is about
so much more than just possible chess it
really tests these gladiators and all of
the different chess formats including
some crowd favorites rapid and blitz
that's what we're gonna get to tomorrow
if no matter what actually it will be
particularly dramatic if the classical
games are drawn
no ifs about it and that's that's the
good thing about
format of this tournament everything
gets showcased and all three formats
will will be seen over the board
that's right did you see our schedule
tomorrow's gonna be wrapping in blitz
followed by playoffs if required then
there's gonna be a rest day for the
players to gear up for the finals or the
third-place match if you find yourself
in that situation he's still got to play
your basket that third-place spot and it
really is a nonstop action week yeah
going into the weekend to finish it off
yesterday was incredibly exciting with
you we only really had one game to cover
but what a game it was but for now let's
listen to Alexandra describe the the way
these four players got to London well
thank you Peter definitely an exciting
game yesterday let's take a look how the
top four got their place here in the
London chest classic the Grantchester
finals starting with Levon Aronian
who going into his final tournament in
India he had it all but secured it were
taking some kind of mathematical miracle
for him not to make it to India to
London but in India he had a terrible
tournament finishing dead last couldn't
wait to get rid of the tournament and it
was thanks to a very strong showing
allison was rapping in blitz and the
super vet rapid and blitz that he really
was able to secure that spot Dingley red
meanwhile he had a comfortable way into
London there was almost no doubt he was
making it to the finals after a very
very strong showing indistinct field cup
defeating magnus carlsen in that epic
playoff the chinese player has had a
really nice year and he's showing why he
is the third best player in the world
meanwhile max eva holograph who was
watching from the sidelines while india
was taking place qualified by the bare
minimum vision and was very close to
overtaking him in the india tournament
but that when in paris was the key for
him to really make it to London and of
course we have the king himself magnus
carlsen he had absolutely no doubts that
he was gonna qualify for this tournament
winning the
opening Grantchester event in Africa
following it up with the win in Croatia
absolutely decisive by that point it was
very clear that Magnus was making it to
London and despite a week showing at the
Simmons rapid in blitz he managed to get
second interesting field cup and crushed
the competition in India so he's
definitely showing excellent chance its
undefeated streak gets extended even
further can he do it one more day today
I guess Mike Seaver allograph well we
have all the action from London where we
have Maurice Ashley Thank You alejandro
well it is indeed a buzz here in London
as the second classical game is about to
begin at least games with these four
players and it's time for bracketology
some of the best minds in all of chess
okay it's just we four commentators who
have gotten some controversy for real
the players we like or don't like well
let's take a look and see what it looks
like starting with first of all Jennifer
Shahadah
who always makes interesting picks well
she's picked Carlsen to be my Sheila
Graham and ding Lorentz beat Aronian and
the final surprise surprise Magnus
Carlsen emerging as champion with maxima
defeating his good friend LaVon for
third place but Alejandro also has
picked Carlsen to win against vasila
Graham and ding to beat Aronian with
ding emerging as the champion in that
matchup and vascular grove again taking
third place and moving now to Peter
Svidler again the pick Carlsen to get
out of that match against mvl this time
Aronian defeating ding Loren once more
though with Carlsen as the champ and
vasila Grove making it to old of losses
anyway for ding Loren and finally well
there have to be real controversy
somewhere my pick yes I've got Carlsen
coming out ahead of I Selig Rob and ding
Laraine defeating a liberal
and along with Alejandra I'm thinking
ding to win it all and Aronian to beat
MBL so none of us agreeing completely
somebody's bracket what may emerge
victorious it'll be only one of us or
maybe none of us if we get a big
surprise but we'll see what happens one
day at a time as we are going to start
the second day here in London well I
can't wait to follow those brackets hey
we could all be out right away if not
see Bobby I got that much sorry Mike
Symons a classical game today with the
white pieces and we're all dead in the
water pretty much with the with the six
six point lead going into the rapid and
blitz tomorrow but Sir we'll see what
happens let's take a look at what we
have on tap for today it's Maxine with
white against Magnus and Ziegler n
taking the white pieces against LaVon
and this particular graphic has been the
entry of the inspiration for four for my
bracket big because I basically picked
people with beards against the one guy
who chose not to wear one because it's
not Movember anymore it's December but
you have a beard I don't get it Tigers
we've got a little yeah I think is a
very confusing right now I don't know
where I'm going with this but you gotta
have a code and for me it was those with
the better eyesight because we will will
have as you can see from from this
cylinder in you know exchange will have
purely Church ethical reasons for for a
briquette picture and here is madness
with his new new fashion accessory he's
been doing this huge green bag for the
second day running I like it so it's
very green and also very big here in st.
Louis really a block away from all foods
he does the the he brings I think they
are not entirely energy drinks they're
more like pale things he puts and puts
them in the fridge somewhere in Armin
well I like this though because he is
obviously a very successful young man
they're playing for $350,000 but here he
is carrying a $1 bag from Whole Foods it
kind of shows like what's important you
know this is recyclable he doesn't care
it's just a matter of getting stuff from
point A to point B which is a good
message you know I was not really
criticizing it's just it's an
interesting look an unusual look but
every time I see those drinks appears in
the fridge I think I'm missing out on
something here this is this looks like a
good strategy so bring your own bag guys
to the grocery store so you can be like
magnus carlsen we don't need a plastic
right first of all that and secondly
maybe this is like the entire
explanation for why he's been crushing
and weave with a telephone in now caught
him done and now there will be a much
closer competition at the top because
people will start coming with maybe
that's the entire explanation and we've
finally figured it out through different
drinks I remember when he was a kid he
used to have bottles and bottles of
orange juice and there was also much
books of books of mixed nuts yeah really
drop them in the floor of I can say a
little bit of us like to see him picking
it up and what a what an outfit here by
the behind running the burgundy and
green not a combination I would have
thought of that man he makes it work
yeah I think his he does this on purpose
he is trying to he's trying to combine
things which have not been combined be
like you know this challenge of like
uttering a sentence and we you know the
words and the sentence that have never
been uttered in the story before and the
one tries I think to do this with
without fits to a degree in a way that
is high fashion isn't it okay gotta do
something new that people still feel
like they've seen before in a certain
way but let's take a look at the the
players as they get ready to play the
games we are gonna have some special
guests make their very first moves
starting with James house who's stepping
up to the board an 8 year old from
Hampton grows Hampton Burnie primary
school in the UK and he's gonna make a
first move for a ding Lorraine and I
think he played before yeah good move
good move James yeah yesterday we had we
had somebody play Knight c3 and then
take it back and play Knight f3 which
feels like he was having fun having a
good time it's good to see these
ceremonial first moves and Malcolm Payne
who you see on the stage right now with
the microphone and Maurice is gonna join
in on the second game ceremonial first
move cuz he knows quite a bit about the
young man Telecom who's gonna make that
move and I see him coming up to the
stage right sulukim Waku as you see him
coming up
he is a phenom from Ghana who I got a
chance to work with while I was there in
our craw last October this October that
just passed and let me tell you this kid
is got major talent he can study chests
for hours and hours and hours a great
passion for the game and one of the
diamonds that we found while they're in
Africa in Ghana so looking forward to
seeing his future you see all smiles
quite an honor for him to be able to do
this and he hasn't played chess for very
long so it's great that Malcolm was able
to bring him on stage also found him
some instructions some private lessons
as well to support his talents doing
great work for chess in schools in the
community and communities is Malcolm
Payne and that's exactly what I was
going his future Malcolm is a great
proponent and that may be the largest
driving force behind the the Chesson
Schools movement in the UK so great work
being done by him yeah that's great for
the years he's always doing a good job
of combining that at the London chest
classic and that's why you see a lot of
youngsters there's different events and
tournaments for the kids as the greatest
players in the world are facing off and
off we go we have a Spanish we have a
tradition in lavon's game not a Berlin
not only in the rock seems concerned
yeah the one was white yesterday I'm
sure right
and LaVon with the black pieces will be
facing a very sharp variation of the
nimzo-indian so that one will hopefully
hopefully hopefully we don't know just
yet we could just get what used to be
called the the tabby of the name Zoe and
I actually haven't seen this played at
the highest level for a while like an
actual an actual Tavia tae-bo of the
names of it we'll we'll see in a moment
and mothers goes for the open Spanish
which is something he's been doing but
not in every single Spanish is he's
played in a baby in the last few years
so interesting if Maxime has something
something special prepared because the
open I think has been doing
exceptionally well recently I think very
few people have but he's not playing the
pure open with b5 he's taking on any
foreign player should be seven yellow I
believe he played this against actually
has had a bit of a resurgence respected
right with the with the line rookie bond
b5 Luke takes d4 d5 I think the Camorra
has also been playing this with black
wasn't it wasn't this like Corona
Nakamura yeah this was I don't think he
was Cara wanna I'm trying to remember
wanna Carlson from Croatia I think that
was the most recent game and before that
I want to say there was like a live long
game I guess
possibly yeah yeah and I'm trying to
figure because I think isn't it we need
to move here I believe it's also a move
because I think at some point the reason
I vaguely remember something along these
lines is that there was a period when
Malakhov was playing this quite actively
with black and I had to prepare against
him and I ended up thinking that I think
this is how this goes right bishop they
take with the be poor now and go to b7
it looks extremely ugly with at first
glance but then the knight often comes
to you know very normal square only six
which is quite good for the night in
these positions and black games to play
either let's say d5 bring the knight
over and then play c5 or sometimes blood
goes for an immediate challenge to the
white central pawn with f6 it says draw
oh no
I was just pointing out that way I have
a game from Croatia ice cream with Ricky
1v5 sure pick c4 sorry I got I got
slightly this life is lecture and just
to I kept them talking about Thai beers
and not showing the position be what
used to be called Thai be of the names
is the position here if if black let's
say goes g5 we Castle black goes knight
c6 a3 Bishop c3 and I think maybe even
more specifically DC for Bishop c4 Queen
c7 used to be known as the Thai beer
which kind of shows how narrow was the
focus when people were just starting to
develop the theory of this opening
because names are in general is just
such a tremendously rich opening you
know white has such a wide choice of
ideas even and move for and somehow this
position was just assigned like the main
position of the opening and there was a
lot of advances there were a lot of
advances made in the theory of this
particular position even in the 50s and
the 60s but it's looking at it from
today's viewpoint is very difficult to
understand why this is so central there
are so many other things you can play
against the names of although the other
hand it is kind of a variation that's
died down I want to say in the last 15
years I really have not seen it at the
level of chess I think mainly because
positions like this have been analyzed
to more or less a draw where the carpet
variation yeah the I think mainly it's
because black realized that this might
be fine but it leads to extremely
complicated positions where occasionally
you will not equalize whereas in
particular this position you need to
study some theory because obviously if
white gets some kind of t45 breaks and
in a in a good addition you will do very
very well but if you do know what you're
doing you will just equalize outright
and your fashion shifted quite a bit
here but the one is still thinking here
and this is maybe the time for me to
briefly mention something I kind of
teased to my to my colleagues in the
studio I looked up the record and I also
in particular I wanted to refresh my
memory
in regards to what happened in there
match in Billie Civic they famously
played the World Cup final in Belize in
2017 which they won ended up winning and
then one said something yesterday at the
press conference he was it was actually
very open normally people tried to hide
these things a little bit and say okay I
didn't get anything out of the opening
and the game just fizzled out he more or
less said that he didn't feel all that
well and he came with the intention of
playing something something solid and
making a draw because he just did not
feel up to playing a full game of chess
against a very strong opponent and then
he was asked so what's your plan for
tomorrow and he said this is very much
like a World Cup match you will get your
chance at some point it doesn't matter
if you're white or black and I looked up
the games and in that final match in
Belize he got absolutely nowhere with
the white pieces in the classical and
was winning in both of the black games
interesting so I think he also has very
specific kind memories of playing
against England in play is kind of
sharply for a win against him and the
position we have on their board right
now perhaps doesn't signify much in the
way of winning chances for black but
still I thought it was somewhat relevant
to mention that his score again staying
in classical chess we have this graphic
but I mean it's a simple stat so I
remember it at 0 3 no victories for left
again sitting and classical but he's
come very close on a number of occasions
and in general I think the dynamic
between them is not at all one-sided so
I think he felt he will definitely get
his shot now that's somewhere when you
talk about honesty do you feel in
interviews that you'd rather have
players be honest even if it's something
that you don't want to hear I think you
know honesty in in general is it's great
and like on a personal note I I myself
have often felt that if I learned at
some point in my career to give sort of
non non answers to questions it would
have probably gone better for me because
there's definitely been cases where I
said a little bit too much in interviews
and later thought why why do I you know
this is a routine question I don't need
to actually deliver it to 2001's say in
reply to it from Vicki
he's really good at that if he doesn't
feel like answering a specific question
the way he spins it to something that he
is interested in I mean obviously I
think that it's really refreshing your
honest answers but sometimes for the
players it can also be really intense
yeah to have to answer something
honestly so that's why we get a kind of
mix but um yeah I agree with you about
LaVon it was interesting to hear his
true thoughts and certainly with this
insane schedule of 2019 you can't blame
anyone for just trying to pick the
strategy that makes them most likely to
win the match whatever they might think
that maybe especially when they're you
know ten years older than their opponent
but I don't even think there was
necessarily a strategic decision it was
I think he was saying exactly how he
felt he just did not feel up to playing
up to playing on that day with simply
the way he felt physically I don't think
he came to London with the idea of
shifting the entire weight of the match
to to wrap it in blitz I think he would
very much like to play his white game
for a win but when you wake up and you
realize you know your brain is in a
state of fog as he describes you do very
seriously consider just sort of cutting
cutting your losses to a degree and
saying yeah well there's three days of
chess here I don't need to I don't need
to push myself past the limit let's
catch up on the game with Magnus this
game is a couple more moves have been
played in that opening they're still
following a couple of important games
thanks to dr. Farahani who was kind of
allowing me to cheat a little
she was looking up the games and this is
the game between Nakamura and karana
from the same field Cup and before that
it was karana against Carlsen from
Croatia and still here Maxime taking
quite a bit of time for a very well
known position to get to this position
here I believe karana just moves
ruthlessly there's also Knight c3 which
i think is a topical line but I want to
see what Magnus has prepared because
Knight c3 in that game between nock
and Khurana wasn't the I wouldn't say a
very clear vanish for white but it did
feel like Nakamura with the white pieces
just obtained a little bit of an
annoying edge against his opponent the
idea of Knight c3 is that you're okay of
course you're taking both pawns and
there will be the chance of especially
installing a knight very quickly on the
c5 square now taking on d5 is possible
at some point especially what black just
castles but this kind of positions where
what is up a pawn but the bishop start
to get so much danger the bishop on
these things probably a bishop on b7 the
Queen sometimes goes to e8 because there
are tactical ideas with the pawn on a4
and bringing the Queen into the game
they can get very very messy and I want
to see if Maxine was paid good enough
attention to this kind of positions to
really get a stronger advantage than
what both of the previous white players
were able to do which was it might have
better not totally convincing in terms
of opening theory you know I think the
the second game I the one I was
referring to once again I'm not entirely
sure I had I was pretty sure it was Fabi
against Hikaru but yeah in that game I
thought probably at some point had a
little something-something with black
dragon was black oh yeah okay Hikaru
then yeah I thought I thought at some
point it looked to me like white was on
the verge of actually stabilizing and
getting yeah he was getting a little bit
of a push and then and then black work
worked all of his problems out and and
even started pushing at some point yeah
at some point over pressed but it did
seem like black did it fully Qantas
positions and that is the most recent
game so I want to see what causes new
idea is going to make I'm sure Maxine is
well aware of that game playing right
next to them and being an opening
specialist and pretty much all he plays
so I want to see what's going to happen
in this game for now Maxine thinking
quite a bit of a thing here he does have
options but this is a well known
position at the top level considering
that two really important games we've
had this year on it yeah and it's it's
interesting to see this
really this has always been very much a
sideline of the Spanish getting so much
traffic at the extreme dope level not
just good players but the absolute best
players of the world all seem to be
suddenly interested in playing this D
for Bishop e7 line which honestly I
never thought was particularly good and
once again I'm somewhat surprised kooky
one who gets gets like exclusive
attention Queen e2 gets none whatsoever
I'm sure he I mean 100 is looking at me
somewhat quizzically I guess he knows
the answer to that no no I don't know
anything this variation at least nothing
public our Queen e2 has its own ideas
but I do have to agree that sometimes
chess fashion just overtakes positions
and of course here in this position
there is no need to play groupie 1
that's an absolute must you can't play
Queen e2 there are other moves that can
even be considered but it feels like
sometimes players like a certain
position fashionably and they try to
figure it out also I found a lot of
positions where the really top level of
chess likes to play a few times so you
had many times but it doesn't even break
the 2600 level like nobody the 26 or
2500 level really wants to take the time
and learn the variation because it's
kind of a fashion fad and people think
it's gonna go away
and I'm sure this is one of those I also
have apologize to our viewers so let me
let me just briefly interrupt you and
take back everything I said because I I
had a bit of a thing yeah and I realized
that the line I was talking about
happens in open Spanish happens in a
completely different different move
order if we could just bring up the
board because I realized that I was like
the position with life on b7 it happens
here because of course you need to play
96 to attack the bishop on d5 otherwise
white will just play d5 here and be
extremely happy and this is where you
get the position with an icon okay and
in the game like if you play Queen e2
here I assume black plays d5 or b5 over
there yeah because my t6d just instantly
looks horrible for black because the
bishop is on a4 and the knife has to go
so some poorer squares I mean like five
yeah but then then you
she run into significant trouble
compared to the Berlin you you actually
get we should be six and Ruby Jiwon in
like once again and we probably taking
up too much time on this but very
famously you can not you would very much
like the plate we need to in this
position maybe but black plays 94 and
this is this is very very important that
rule Devon never really gets played with
tonight on the five stock and now after
Knight takes d4 Queen takes d4 rookie
154 black is instantly arguably slightly
better this is why nobody plays Queenie
soon I mean I don't think you're taking
up too much time I think this is
fascinating for the viewers because it
shows the underpinnings of why the
theory has developed in a way that the
top players are playing to Berlin and
yeah I think I think I mean this is sort
of well known little detailed but it
bears repeating I guess for somebody who
may not have seen this this little bit
know because if you look at the top
players games that this is not in the
notes because everybody just to see
everybody everybody assumes that
everybody knows but I guess there there
there must be some people out there who
never asked themselves like we need to
is not a move in this position and it's
very very specifically only because of
94 was it would make perfect sense and I
assume if you play well you don't really
want to play Queen you on because then
you can play Rick do you want even even
94 anyways yeah but he also not creating
a threat to 51 and in this position once
again because we have already included
Queen e2 and Bishop e7 Bishop takes c6 I
have to say to say it wins but I have a
suspicion you might actually have to
take with the b-pawn because DC six this
631 after play Bishop d7 and now he
seeks followed by 95 might just win on
the spot
you might also just not yeah I mean in
some cases it doesn't but often this is
very very strong so you might you might
have to be taking with the people on and
unlike just has a very comfortable game
and but all in all me saying why you buy
all these people play rookie one here in
North we needs who has been a bit of a
bit of a mix-up which will although it
doesn't go into those four issues but it
doesn't mean that Queen e2 is not
playable in this position okay so it's a
move but yeah
it's not the main move I assumed it was
because I had my brain completely
scrambled there for a second but it's
actually interesting because it seems
like for the second round in a row
you're not that excited about Magnus is
opening in preparation would you say
that's accurate exciting yesterday I
mean no no excited like the game was
exciting but you know the combination of
f3 and Bishop g5 doesn't make the
strongest impression not the strongest
impression no but we were extremely
excited about it yesterday because it
kind of promised us a whole new concept
and it delivered on that promise because
we had a very very non-standard neither
of on the board where people actually
had to take very interesting strategic
decisions this one I mean it's less
surprising because as we've been talking
we've been discussing for a while now
this suddenly is somewhat fashionable
and he's plated himself in Croatia yeah
what I meant by excited more was like
excited if you were part of Magnus's
team for instance
in that respect like are you happy with
the outcome of this opening well it's
not really an outcomes well you're say
right I mean we're just kind of waiting
to see what my team's gonna bring into
the game because this is a known
position we're just starting we're just
starting no idea so we're gonna have to
wait until Maxime makes some kind of
commitment at this point I am expecting
Knight c3 which was he Cara's choice and
I thought it was the more dangerous
variation but Maxime seems to be taking
quite a bit of time here isn't b3 Bishop
a3 b3 sigh thing you know another idea
yeah and yeah Queeny one what's that
game I was thinking about of LaVon and
Mama Diarra from the Olympiad I want to
say yeah yeah yeah which was quite a
brilliant game if I remember correctly
by my med or was he completely losing
which one was the one no I think he won
a very very poor position in the game
that's right yeah you know he won was
cruising and then he started making
really strange decisions and allowed a
lot of play for I think two extra pawns
that he could at some point I could have
had them in in any number of ways and he
chose a very strange one letting all of
black pieces sort of roam free giving a
lot of counter play where he really
didn't have to and from that moment on I
think Jacques played a stunningly
stunningly good game I mean here we see
Maxime really sinking deep into God now
you imagine he knows his position and we
see this all the time though people
thinking into thought even if it's a
position that they presumably studied I
think it very much depends on whether
you expected it for this particular game
and repeated you know it's sort of on
the morning of the game because somebody
like Maxime who does a tremendous amount
of work it's very difficult to keep all
of it fresh in your fresh in your mind
so in that case at what point are you
trying to remember the notes and at what
point you're just trying to think about
the position on your own like how how do
you decide when to switch from one to
the other you know it depends on like
how much actual work you've done on the
position because if if you know that
your notes are very good and you've come
to a conclusion you like put your
somewhat hazy own move orders you might
want to invest some more time and trying
to remember but if you know it's just
say you know this seems to be a decent
way to reply and then like this is
playable this is you know not a
variation you need to study in great
deal in great depth just go go play
chess then at some point I think you
just give up and start making sensible
moves and start thinking on your own and
I think it's interesting because for
some players there might be a difference
in the way that they look because
obviously the way it feels to think
about a position and to try to remember
some
is kind of different yeah of course
sometimes you were actually just
deciding between two different
variations it's possible that my team
has looked at two different ones they
lead to completely different style of
positions and I was about to mention
that because here I think 93 potentially
at least yeah it's too much much sharper
play compared to two because I see three
you probably will be will be obliged to
accept some kind of not obliged
necessarily but at least you have an
option of accepting some porn sacrifices
and then trying to prove the
compensation is insufficient whereas if
you look at the position of to be three
castles Bishop a3 you are probably not a
lot better but you run more or less zero
risk
can you explain after ninety three
castles yeah like I said a condor was
showing the positions of the positions
in particular positions like this which
you often see in the marshals as well
there is a very definite marshal issue
I've about this euro con g5 is not stuck
as such there's plenty of squares on the
fifth-ranked you can play it but it's it
has a very difficult difficult way back
home so it will provide black with a lot
of temp it's who to develop his pieces
to good squares there's also the the
usual finish voyage the idea is maybe
not immediately because that actually
gives white a very nice Rock h5 tempo
but there should be 7 followed by
something followed by something else and
it's a lot easier to play with black
generally positions like this because
black has all of these nice nice
attacking or at least dynamic
opportunities on every move and you do
take a very significant I wouldn't call
it a strategic risk it's a it's more of
a kind of short-term tactical risk
because you've badly misplaced one of
your heavy pieces and if you don't solve
that problem it might actually kind of
plague you for the rest of the game
right on the other hand you're up upon
and the black pawn structure is not
gonna get too much better so if you can
somehow consolidate although you can
pretty much cruise to win yeah but it's
a very difficult game then if we look at
b3 you're never gonna win that pawn but
what you do you do trade off the the one
right what I'm told good bishop which
goes to the six and then you know has
as attacking prospects on the kingside
you immediately traded off for the one
on a three black is left with a somewhat
poor bishop on c8 and even let's say in
this position if black just does nothing
for two moves and you play an IP one
back you play nice III you force a Bab
you put this night on c5 you're sort of
strategically winning by this point so
black has to be very very quick
challenging and I think they play Queen
b6 here and follow it up almost
immediately with with c5 and then try to
make that work tactically because it
looks like forgiving this position after
let's say Knight c3
maybe you should actually include a b3
earlier because now everything is
hanging what's a b3 a b3 c 593 even here
it feels like you give white a tempo
somewhere to just let's say play Knight
a for 464 and then bring the rook vector
good square it's a very very comfortable
stable plus for the rest of the game so
you're saying that you need to do
Knights you you need to do c5 right away
because are there like otherwise like
work a5 for instance if we take well
yeah I think I think a five would be a
tough it just gonna just an e6 er yeah
anything that really puts control over
the dark squares yeah make that bishop
so bad
there will be that's a very very good
move that you're pointing out here Jeff
because once we see make sure CC 5075
doesn't happen this Bishop never really
comes comes back to life and much team
after some thought actually does choose
the Stabler stable approach that's right
that's right he does he does played b3
as I think what Alejandra was pointing
out about you know deciding between
those two moves and obviously thinking
about his prep for a Brooke takes e5 and
those crazy lines might have Ian if he's
not a hundred percent confident this is
a safer option so to go over those lines
you were just looking at what point did
you want to insert a takes b3 again I
think castles castles already happened
yeah play Bishop e3 and you see on your
screen this has been flowing right
stakes you play Queen d6
I mean Quincy one exists but I don't
know what it does you kind of you're
taking your queen away from good squares
actually and especially the knight wants
to reach yeah and the knight has to
return anyway maybe one and if you play
c5 here after
see three you might be 110 for short
because I think rook takes d5 actually
might actually be a move here yes yeah
so if you if you want to play c5 if you
have to insert a b3 here and play c5 93
once again and now what about what about
work 85 in that position hmm
but a different move by - instead of
this idea of Queen d6 which I thought
was automatic rook e8 being played yeah
this is so once again mom is showing
that they've taken this variation series
is there a little just copying what
other people are doing and we're hearing
from Rouge Nicole beyond that Moroz
officially this against Roger Bob in
2012 Thank You VAR yeah and that was a
drama yeah it makes some sense to to get
some some more pieces of the board but
once again it you slowed down your own
counter play with c5 by a tempo
seemingly let's say we take take and
sort of the I understand you're
describing Knight pigma heavy one as a
caveman approach it's like slightly
weird because normally the caveman
approach is trying to give mate and not
just bringing the piece back to a good
square but position okay bad yeah
there's not much else to do for a while
unfortunately yeah I think really keep
trading 22 with the intention of
bringing the recover and only after that
starting on the whole on the whole not
be one c3 maneuver might be another
there might be an argument for that
that's a bit slow right if I play
something like Bishop e6 I might even
think at some point I'm gonna get a
takes b3 and go a 585 by four yeah this
this is in particularly if we take the
rook away from the a file I think
Alejandro is absolutely correct maybe
there is some argument for taking with
the C pawn and saying you can play 584
I'll just play before and reply and the
thing is all of these positions I think
it would be fair to describe them as not
that bad but black never really feels
like he's completely equal until a lot
later in the game because once again if
you imagine this Knight just somehow you
know the white sort of correcting the
piece by you know using
the sleeve of his jacket you know as
they as they do in in part games just
whilst pressing the clock when playing
see two things b3 you just adjust adjust
unite from a three to a four and white
is instantly close to winning again
obviously it's difficult to you know in
a classical game in front of yeah but
whenever you move a night it always goes
from a dark square light square so there
we go why not a four no no I like that
point though theater because this is not
a phrase that you use lightly
strategically winning that what I do I
get I guess understanding these players
are but that's this is for real this
time like if we could move a night to a
for you really well be black would be
extremely unhappy yeah sometimes you
don't lose those positions because
there's very little material left and
you can kind of hang on grimly and hope
that the conversion technique is
somewhat lacking on the day but yeah the
position is bad because there are
strategic deficiencies which you will
just not be able to resolve until until
the game finishes and the reason that
you're reluctant to say these days is
because people are such great defenders
from using computer engines so when you
say it you really mean it although of
course people would not normally get
themselves into a situation where their
opponent has a knight on c5 ya know
obviously black will will do something
like you can you can start by playing
Queen d7 here and if the knight goes to
C 2 then you probably don't play c5
because you don't want to allow the
night to go to the four in one temper
but don't see to it actually doesn't
progress very well towards the a four
square you can play five here for
instance and if you play not be one here
you might very seriously consider
playing c5 because the knight
compared to the previous position
doesn't get to d4 that quickly you still
obviously prefer white here up to 93 I
think it's it's very safe to say that
when you see structures like this
the knife will always be slightly better
than the bishop on e6 but once again
very limited material should not be the
end of the world after something like I
don't know Queen b6 or yeah that's a
typical way of solving problems to trade
pieces and you defend a slightly worse
position in which perhaps you don't have
that many weaknesses on the opponent's
plan it's not that clear like in this
case rather take white but how often do
you really win it exactly like how many
how many out of ten right at this level
do you do you win with white and the
number will be quite low I think even
the number should cover somewhere
between two and three out of ten and how
would that change Peters it was a rapid
game then you feel like that number
starts to go up because there's more
chances for than stakes or not
necessarily I think in this position
once again it's it's hugely dependent on
the level of the players I think at this
level where people have very you know
that they've experienced defenders they
know they know what the way for they
know how to approach these positions I
think the number generally goes up when
you switch from classical to rapid but
it's not gonna be like a dramatic shift
from two to eight out of ten so for
those of you who might have questions
for me Peter and Alejandro we do have
our phone lines open in the classical
games three one four three six one five
four six five give us a call make it a
good question tips are making it a good
question keep it to one question and if
you can relate it in some way to the
grand chest tour or maybe to one of the
players or to the state of modern chess
something that relates vaguely to what
we're doing here today that's a bonus
yeah and finally you can also tweet at
us using the hashtag grande chest we're
finals our twitter handle at grande
Chester is being woman to by tata bob
raha me on so you can also interact with
her if you have a question that doesn't
end up getting on the air
and we should probably talk about the
other yeah second day second day running
we're doing this these treaties on one
out of two and sort of ignoring the
second one and it is drier than although
today I'm not even so sure it's a bit
puzzling to me the current thing that
Dingley around us on he basically chose
the variation that we're playing he
taking on d5 perhaps we can go through
the game a little bit yeah let's go back
to the start of an Enzo and dingos 443
which is you know one of the main ways
of replying to to the names of castles
night of three c5 Bishop d3 and here
instead of playing g5 which like if you
were aiming for those positions you I
think you could play g5 here but he goes
cd4 8485 here and which I think if you
castles not a big difference right yeah
I think it should be more or less
exactly the same and here ding ops 465
which is obviously not a novelty by any
stretch but maybe he just expected light
automatically take with a knight because
it's perfectly fine here right and
didn't really consider the the idea of
recapturing with the pawn their
seriously because normally I think in
the names Oh with the bishop already on
d3 and this is by far the best diagonal
for this bishop in these symmetrical
positions the understanding generally is
that white is slightly better in all of
these positions and people don't really
like playing them with black all that
much so it's very natural maybe for your
attention to shift away from from that
option for left but left is seems
undeterred and he just played 85 and
very quickly played Bishop g4 which is
by far the main line of the position you
know and h3 Bishop h5 is now on the
board h3 played after very long
lightning with Iran so perhaps either
not familiar with the position perhaps
they didn't really consider that this
was going to happen because after it
takes d5 you do kind of have to castle
with white there is you know nothing
else you can do and Bishop g4 is by far
the main move for this position
yeah we'll we'll see you we'll see what
transpires it still is
despite being somewhat symmetrical it
seems like a position that could become
very sharp and very concrete let's save
Bishop g5 creates immediate threats so
we're not we're not expecting the quiet
game today and we don't have a phone
call that's right from Omaha welcome to
the show let us know your name in your
question
hello this is Carlos my question is
regarding the current time control but
the total four hours give or take and
I'm curious of y'all take on the time
line not really based on looking at any
particular tournament like the World
Championship or whatever the case may be
but just how do y'all feel about the
time and because as a fan you know we
can look at four hours you know but as a
you know four eight nine now was this
kind of hard to chant put that in there
so I'm just curious just as a announcer
atomically analyst what do you think of
it that's a that's a good question
because thanks for that cause because
this is a very specific time control
which I don't think is being run
currently anywhere else it might catch
on and I think it's a product of
years and years of discussions in
particular I played in a couple of
Sinquefield cups here and I've been
working as a as an analyst for a couple
of years as well and there are parties
and at parties did instead of discussing
you know things of Universal important
but is well insert things of University
for because here people still end up
discussing the best way to promote chess
and the best way to package it so that
audiences could keep their interest
going and I remember one party in
particular which I think was during a
baseball game and once again what were
we doing instead of watching a baseball
game over we were engaged in a heated
discussion on the on the chess time
controls and I think originally the
single cups in particular they were they
were full-on seven hour time control
tournaments and at some point people
including people running the tournaments
started coming to the conclusion that
this is untenable this is just way too
long people drift off it's it's very
hard on the players it's not great for
the announcers as well and in general
it's just not something that
people people like necessarily and the
time control you see right now which is
two hours give a give or take is the
next way of describing it it's 2:10 for
the entire game with the 30-second delay
is I think a very concerted effort to
make the game long enough so that people
can I mean there's no doubt that this is
a classical game let's put it like this
we know we're we're watching a classical
game people will have enough time to to
go into the tank if they need so we've
seen this yesterday when Magnus at some
point spent something like 50 minutes on
Tokyo on two moves in a row right I mean
combined not not not 50 and 50 but like
25 and 20 or something
so there's definitely plenty of time if
the position is extremely complex for
you to dive where is it and and try to
figure a way out of it
but it's also a manageable amount of
time because with the delay if it goes
into a long end game it might be maybe
five hours and five hours is I think
accepted as as a good game good good
length for for a classical game so I
think it's an interesting time
controller I quite like it
the one the one objection you could have
to it is that you would very much like
for for a table chess player to be
playing consistently with the one time
control everywhere because you you do
you do get kind of
[Music]
mixed up a bit yeah like all the Feder
tournaments are being played with a
different time control and these are
like the most important tournaments in
terms of fighting for the title well so
I definitely I agree with you that it
would be a little nice to have
consistency but on the other hand I like
the different time controls I think they
provide different avenues for the
players to fight in even if they're both
just different types of classical
personally I really like as a
commentator this particular classical
time controls because we don't have this
lull after move 40 which I really feel
strongly against when I'm a commentator
I feel that the players for each move 40
and they both tank forever nothing
really happens and it's like the action
really builds up up to the 40th move and
then suddenly there's a big drop on the
level of interest in the games almost at
the same time whereas I feel here you
have this consistency good pace going on
now it's a commentator I really prefer
rapid games but if I have to pick a
classical time control for me it's this
one all the way compared to the other
ones I've done everywhere we've also
done a tower broadcasts in which the
game just never ended yeah and you still
have to play it out it's just part of
the part of the deal I like this one
I think delay is not something I'm ever
gonna be really fond of but I don't
think there's any perfect solution for
that one and I think delay is fine you
know very but in general I think I think
it's oh it's a very nice time control
what do you think well I like it because
it's not it's one where you get more
emphasis on the opening and middle game
I feel like the one with the extra hour
for the end game really privileges the
end game stage especially when you have
increment so we were seeing like
openings and middle games that were a
little bit rushed followed by you know
our end game and that allowed some kind
of interesting strategic elements where
a player could grind grind grind and and
gave it maybe in a slightly artificial
way that almost gave short shrift to the
middle game stage so yeah I think this
is this is good in it I also like the
one with like a 30 minute bonus for the
end game but we do have a Maurice Ashley
on site
in to weigh in as well definitely for
you going to play classical chess I
think this time control is an
improvement over the past time controls
exactly as Alejandro said the idea that
the action bills and bills and bills and
there is no real law the players will
have to learn to adjust to your point
engine the idea that you want to keep
some time remaining so you can play for
accuracy in the endgame and these
players have shown it just simply time
and time again that no matter what time
control you put in front of them if they
get a chance to practice it over time
they'll adjust make the the kind of
thought thoughtful decisions in the
openings in the middle game that allow
for them not to get into huge time
pressure near the end and as long as we
don't have those tremendous laws then
sure you want to play chess like this I
think I think this is the ideal so far
that we found for classical chess Thank
You Maurice is somebody who's only
trying to make the game more exciting
it's not like we have a lot of listener
today in the south so welcome to the
show from Kentucky hi Josiah I have a
question about some who you think the
biggest threat is to Magnus and the
upcoming candidates tournament and in
particular what you all think about ding
Lauren's recent track record against
Magnus at least in rapid games well
thank you for your question I'm gonna
let be completely unbiased on 100 or
Mira's startup who's the biggest threat
to bags in the candidates I mean I think
there are two people that stand above
the rest
going into the candidates and dust are
gonna be the two 2000s I mean as Russian
commentator Mary Cheng who likes to say
they have ratings for a reason and I
think Fabien Dingley Ren are still clear
favorites as clear fairness you can be
in such a tough tournament with eight
players and so many rounds in which
really anything can happen but if I had
to put my money somewhere it would be
between those two and of course I have a
slight bias for team Fabi but he's still
the highest rated player outside of
Magnus Carlsen and I still think he has
the best chance of winning the
candidates now regarding ding Lorenz
record against - I think that's awesome
I think it really puts some kind of
rivalry there between players that
Magnus has some trouble against England
and he had said that even before the
start of the Croatia Grantchester when
he was asked who do you have promise
against in this tournament and he was
saying that this fight is records
Dingley ran
he felt that he didn't really get the
types of games that he wants against the
Chinese player that he was a big threat
so I'm sure that Bingley Ren is
something that Magnus is going to have
very prescient in his mind what is going
on against this player that results are
just not there in the very recent rapid
ability events I mean we'll see it right
here at the grand Chester finals it's in
Berlin work to win and Magnus work they
were both to lose then they would clear
their face back also true we could we
could get that in one of two ways
and this is also the answer I gave
yesterday so we are somewhat unoriginal
here but it does feel like the correct
you know you know this huge air quotes
there but the correct answer based on
based on current form it's going to be a
very interesting kind of this tournament
with the people currently likely to get
in once again one player who doesn't
really have a stellar record as far as I
can remember against Magnus but he
always plays very interesting games
against Magnus is it is under Grisham
yeah and he's for instance you know one
thing that stands out in my mind is I
think it was in the world Rapids I think
the one that Vichy was rightly the one
in in Saudi where Magnus lost to
depreciate with the white pieces in the
last round very few people have beaten
Magnus on demand with the black pieces
in the last round of an important event
that Magnus badly wanted to win so
Grichuk is somebody who is I think
particularly motivated by playing
against the world's best but the record
is is not stellar as I mentioned I think
his classical record against Magnus is
is quite quite significantly negative
but they do play they do play very
interesting very fighting chess
if you want to name like an outsider for
for for you know the best shot at Magnus
but first of all he needs to get in he's
almost there yeah he's always white
there and yeah and then I would still
rate him in third behind behind Fabi and
and ignorant yeah we still have to see
who qualifies because it still could be
Maxime Bashar like robbed that ball at
fights I think he would be an excellent
third place chance outside of ding
Loretta and Fabi the other players that
are currently and they're not the most
active players in Rajab of Hon Wong how
but it's just one tournament and in good
preparation good form I mean any of them
could win the event when we say that
Deng lira and Fabia have probably the
highest chances I don't think we're
giving them a combined 50 percent know
to win the event so no they're not even
close to that I wanted to return a
little bit back to chess because we do
have more moves between mvl and Magnus
and Magnus showing as usual very good
preparation playing exactly how the
computer recommends actually finds a
pretty much ideal placement for his
pieces and let me explain what's going
on after the move Knight takes 83 rookie
ed we had left us off in this position
in the game between Bala I'm Raja of
nada morozova travel game that one when
Queen d6 rook takes the eight Queen
takes the eight Queen d2 this idea of
putting the rook on e one looks very
logical we had looked at this plan maybe
put the Queen on d6 push a normal c5 the
bishop runs three six and we did think
that white would be a little bit better
than those kind of positions not
significantly you could probably hold
this with black most of the time but
Magnus doesn't even want to be a little
bit worse he instead puts the bishop on
f5 the rook on e1 and the Queen on c6
and the idea of this configuration is
very simple you attack the c2 pawn and
if you move the c2 pawn to c3 your
Knights trapped because I will just take
it with my bishop
whenever it moves off of a3 and then you
just don't have enough pieces to win the
game and I think that's the analysis of
the position yeah that's very very
succinct and that that mentioned that
Magnus is playing like a computer here
we're not implying anything untoward
he's basically just done his homework
yeah the reason why he's playing this
like a computer is that he's analyzing
this with
and he knows what the computer says and
obviously with him choosing this line
for today's game the ideas are very
fresh in his mind he doesn't need to to
thank very hard here to remember exactly
what he's supposed to do he's actually
no that's not true he is almost game
time
he's only used like this and there's no
increment so this is this is pretty
close to a media play no meanwhile
indicting Moran Levon Aronian game he
also has a few moves including one that
changes the character of the position
yeah g4 is a very welcome sight for us
as as viewers and just lovers because
this promise is a sharper game than it
could have been otherwise I'm interested
in the follow-up digging Aaron is
planning on 95 it's something you could
do I'm always also very interested in
the idea of playing Bishop g5 because it
asks the immediate question of like how
do you respond to the threat of Bishop
takes of six and nine takes d5 I guess
you just take on c3 in particular now
that you four has been played you're a
lot less worried about things like
maintaining the parity of the bishops on
the board and you can play 96 you can
play nine BG 727 there is any number of
things you can you can try here it
doesn't like a particularly nice point
to take on c3 because as you mentioned
once the bishops are taken off we do
have a strategically dangerous position
you are white no g4 is a very very
double-edged moving could backfire quite
badly if if why doesn't follow it up
energetically enough which is why I was
mentioning 95 with the interaction of
maybe playing a for later and you know
establishing this the stronghold but the
thing is let's say the knight gets in
instantly challenged by something like
takes takes 96 and I mean a4 is a poor
move here but I will just put it on the
board as illustration you are probably
instantly in in quite some trouble here
with white because you've allowed this
night to land only four and eventually
this one will get chased away by six or
maybe even traded in some positions and
black has excellent play along the C
file against the weakened c3 pawn this
is just a dream position for black and
by the way this g4 has only been three
played three times and Malikov did play
this once but with
the asterisk so that he did played in a
rapid again against somebody rapid game
against somebody rated and 900 points
lower than him so at that point I'm not
really sure he was showing his best
theory I think he just wanted to mix it
up in that particular game and I assume
he probably end up winning but the skill
differential may have been the the
larger part of it yeah I mean it makes
sense of course if you're playing a much
lower rated player to try to avoid
trades and mix up the position but in
this case being around with g4 is
certainly welcome sight for the
commentators but is it a good sign for
digging around it could also be a
welcome sight for Levon Aronian I think
it is I think Liv enjoys this right now
yeah it's also an interesting decision
for dealing around because I think many
times when you get surprised in the
opening you take a solid approach and
you know if you get Bishop H Bishop g4
in the position there's so many things
what I can do to just make the position
more or less dull I mean you could play
after h3 Bishop h5 not g4 just like
Bishop g5 field above Bishop b3 which is
a bit passive maybe doesn't make a lot
of sense but it's okay there's a million
things I can do and not be worse the
mood chief or indicates a fight and it's
something that you're doing very well
aware that your opponent knows that the
position is good for him after Bishop g6
in the synthetic it cannot be worse for
black you're just going for a fight
saying I'm here let's go I'm gonna push
my king side pawns forward I don't
really care that I haven't seen this
position before let's just go and well
it stands because at the moment this is
a very committal thing from the ignorant
and also notably like this is something
I keep on you know harping on whenever i
commentate on high-level chess but it's
it's slightly in Congress to to play g4
and then tank again right yeah like
you've made this decision you must have
had a follow-up in mind why are you why
are you there he's been thinking on this
I mean not not that much it's only five
minutes but g4 forces Bishop g6
it's not like Bishop six comes as a huge
shock to you why why are you still why
is still not not making your next move
which once again confirms that he wants
a complicated game but he's not entirely
sure exactly how to proceed about
getting a complete
came where he also likes his position
right which would be a nice bonus yeah
right I had 95 96 so what do you like
instead of a 4 well if I think we take
on these three I don't know although why
are you staying honestly 96 also looks
great yeah also allowing 96 and just
playing this position is also I think
completely fine although I honestly I
would prefer to take the bishops off
because here I can imagine white I don't
know some kind of 90 to 93
I don't like we start with probably
should be three or maybe ninety two
first looks very nice for black though
the more I look at this the more I think
yeah this is completely playable and
maybe maybe just as good or maybe even
better than Bishop takes T three lines I
was actually thinking about taking with
the F pawn not really h1 yeah that also
is is an option it normally wouldn't be
that great because you are really not
supposed to you're supposed to take
towards the center you know they teach
you in in the proverbial soviet
kindergarten they teach you to come
towards the center and never and never
away from the center but here opening
opening the F file for Europe definitely
makes some sense
I don't think White's King site is
weakened enough to justify it
necessarily like I feel like here I will
play which p3 and I don't think I'm
going to get mated on the kingside
anytime soon really but then then again
like something like there should be six
followed by Renault rook c8 Bishop e8 I
wanted to end 26 you know yeah we'll
just make me at some point very possibly
alright or Queen d6 through k-8 and then
Bishop a5 Bishop c7 you can go about
these things in a number of ways
yeah Queen needs extra key idea in
Florence Rick takes it yeah that's
that's a very good point not Queenie six
even let's say after something like a
three we can throw in who ke8 and it's
not the best move in the position but
it's a natural move you can make because
drawing line after 23 I'm sure you
probably yeah probably is a joy if we
just continue showing this for a second
black obviously has an immediate drove
it just just the repetition but I do
have more with 90 because the rules get
traded in Queen f1 back yeah first of
all kind of fun [ __ ] but even I think no
Queen e2 you you probably want to do
this for black with the Queen on g3
that's that's very fair that's very
relevant actually queens III king h1 and
we take even here that's very cute we
can still click win a phone check
because here we have look if won in the
end but we're discussing something
that's very clearly will happen you're
supposed to show that black is doing
really well in that particular line you
need to find something more testing for
white and indeed being right did not
play 95 and instead played an 82 yeah
and I feel I feel a lot better about my
little ran towards like a day at the
very beginning of the show because it
does feel like another one of those
games where they've just placed
something perfectly sensible with black
and ding says no I am going to have a
sharp game today if it kills me and
proceeds to might kill him it might
actually kill you might I think black is
black should just be comfortably
somewhat better yeah it's not how they
taught me how to play chess you don't
play g4 and then Knight and it's even
even if you don't go for anything fancy
at all if you just take take and play
knight c6 because I think there might be
an argument for playing 94 straight away
here if you can if you don't lose the d5
pawn somehow after something like
neither for Queen b3 instantly because I
want to if I play that she seeks I have
a suspicion why it goes Bishop g5 and
that pin might become a bit annoying
because let's say you play we should be
7 I play 93 and once again I've stopped
94 or at least I've attempted to stop 94
because of the move actually still
exists right and this is all very
theoretical because we're saying that
blacks not being very ambitious by just
releasing the tension thinking on d3 but
we could also just consider it starting
with another move trying to figure out
exactly what how wide is going to finish
his development and there's a night
really going to go to a force they're
gonna go to cheats I think it probably
goes to g3 because I don't think it does
very much on the floor unless once again
unless there is some concrete play
connected with nine to four full of by
g5 and then immediate attack against the
g5 porn but those lines I think then
even if you win this do you five pony
you might just compromise your kingside
situation to such honest
that you're just not gonna enjoy your
extra point very much so yeah Bishop
takes c3 is by no means forest but it
kind of it brings clarity we and I
generally quite like having clarity in
positions but there's also an argument
for keeping the tension and continuing
to ask King to calculate everything in
the position like from a practical
standpoint the more choice you give your
opponent the more he will burn time yeah
there's no less there's no need to train
the bishop right away and you can
imagine the bishop being comfortable and
e4 in some variations sure and yeah if
no one wants to clarify the position
with mission takes d3 there's nothing
really wrong about it but if he wants to
keep tension and take his chances with
the black pieces I think once you play
chief or your perfectly entitled to do
so no I think live on by this point is
extremely interested and we once again
want to briefly return to the point that
if you actually do in the classical
micro match you are more than halfway
there yeah you are just such a
tremendous favorite going into the final
day of rapid and blades with it like +1
birthday not to win a rapid game and
then they'd also have to go +1 in the
blade yeah yeah either zero in the rapid
which is you know never never very easy
against the standard of players or you
have to win both they both the rapid and
the blitz more just just to tie and
that's that's not to win the match
that's just to tie the match the fact
that I think it's a fair scoring system
because of course you want the classical
would be worth more than the rapid and
here we see it we've got our final
classical game today followed by rapid
and blitz tomorrow playoffs if required
and then we have our finals where we'll
see - classical games followed by rapid
and blitz and here's how the prize money
breaks down $350,000 at stake including
a guaranteed six figures if you get to
the finals math and as for point
breakdown as we were talking about six
points for each classical game is at
stake four point three rapid game and
two for each blitz so in order to make
up for losing
Oh game you can do the math you either
have to completely dominate the Blitz
with three wins and one draw or I think
the most realistic way to come back
would be to go plus one and the rapid
and plus one in the Blitz yeah but even
that only gets you a playoff so very
tough order
yeah and that of course makes it I mean
there are obviously two approaches to
this and we're seeing I think madness
today with the black pieces saying now
that I haven't won that Sicilian
yesterday which he went all out to try
to win yesterday he pulled he pulled no
punches whatsoever but today he's
playing a line which is extremely safe
but also normally doesn't give black
much in a way of winning chances is zero
and he says it's perfectly fine let's
just play tomorrow I'm good at those
shorter time controls even though Maxime
throughout the year hasn't been an easy
opponent for him in rapid and blitz even
the tournament that Magnus has won he
has had some problems I've been leaving
a hobby Jackie went wasn't 0-3 or I
think 0-2 in the business not sure if
you lost the rapid as well but he
definitely lost I think both played
games and there was a topic we've been
discussing when we were covering India
that in both of his absolutely dominant
performances in the rapid and blitz
events both in Abidjan and in India he
lost only two games and both and both of
them to the same player right and that
happened again in India when he lost
only two and both of them to the
ignorant and we are going to take a
quick break here as we will come back
for more exciting action and Game two of
the classical portion of the semi-final
stay tuned
[Music]
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015 SLU
partner with the same Lewis Chess Club
to start a top-tier collegiate chess
team on the very first year of the
team's inception Slough obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
founded in 1939 the University of
Missouri is steeped in tradition with
more than 30,000 students Mizzou is
known for its high academic standards
music program and athletic tradition
this fall another competitive team will
be added to the campus and its
long-standing tradition of excellence
I'm Kristin karala the head coach of
Mizzou's chess team and we will compete
against the nation's top collegiate
programs and represent the Tigers all
around the country Mizzou chess coming
fall 2019
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys gonna see this
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health and strength it's the sound
of compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back at around two of the
London chess classic finals the
Grantchester finals in the Olympia
conference center right in London
England what a great city to visit
especially when there's this type of
elite chess going on Peter and we have
two battles underway one of them the
game between Maxine bot surely Robin
Magnus Crossan looks like the case with
Magnus is exceptionally well prepared
and it might be hard to Mac team to
crack his defenses yeah that game feels
like you you always have to say to say
these things but it does feel like it's
extremely likely to end peacefully
because why doesn't really have anything
but it's also kind of hard to imagine
how you compromise your position with
white here to a degree that black starts
playing for a win it's just very very
solid and as you mentioned Magnus he
generally is extremely well prepared
these days gone are the days of Magnus
just playing whatever comes into his
head on the day and and trying to wing
it these days these days you you know
you are going to be shown something
something serious in the opening yeah
and in this case Maxime really obtaining
very little there have been a couple of
moves played since we last took a look
but it does really fall under the same
ideas instead of putting the point of C
3 we can see Maxine pushed it all the
way to C 4 but that is gonna force a bit
of a commitment out of him coming up
because you can't really keep the
tension forever okay I was wondering if
there's if there's any any chance at all
what might be slightly better here with
a pool on h3 I could maybe make an
argument that this is not that bad
because you have ideas of both rocky 5
and 93 with the idea to follow it up
with D 45 even that doesn't divide that
much but maybe it's a little bit of
progress being made but you know the way
the piece is set up currently if
something like Rome GA might just be
that equal yeah because you can't play
rook e5 anymore because obviously the
the back rank problems bite you here and
if you if you start with 93 the Queen
might go to just lets 87 and black wants
to play Bishop e6 and attack all of
whites
you could even be a little bit more yeah
go Queenie five that line also that
repeat doesn't help because there's
still a background problem right yeah I
missed it and that's a very nice spot
but yeah it doesn't work here I just
didn't see it coming to be honest but it
loses to move take c8 so you're
absolutely right yeah and CD five played
by much same so we might be headed
somewhat took towards those positions
right not a lot of choices here for
Magnus you have to take that bond yeah
25 nights ago there's all sorts I mean
immediately should be six also makes
some sense but here I was maybe hoping
to play rookie five followed by defying
although once again I'm not sure it
works right aqueous frequent xp3 or even
room to rearrange my area it might all
it might all just not work at all for a
while if Bishop e6 the movie is a move
you can make I think you just make it
because now Rudy eight I mean you can
imagine scenarios where white might have
to be somewhat careful because miss
bishop on e6 is a very strong piece kind
of eyeing the the weakness on b3 which
it's not that easy to to find time to
play b3 before for instance somewhere
look the structures changed radically
you remember that solid ideas the
white-hot against weaknesses from black
and you almost want to say that it's
black that has somewhat somewhat more
pressure against White's pawns being
compensated right now by the peace
activity yeah I think that's very fair
and I think this is where that that very
nice idea that you've highlighted in the
previous segment where with Bishop c5 or
Queen six making sure that the night
stays on that Foursquare on a three and
never actually gets to B 1 and C 3 which
was clearly the dream here for for Emile
2594 on the board as we as we speak but
I think our focus will still very
heavily be on the second game where the
one our onion has an absolute dream
position by more fifteen with the black
pieces and also significantly more time
on the clock so
he should be extremely happy above the
outcome of the opening earning time look
at heeda LaVon he spent what is it 13
minutes to get to this position
yeah it's confusing because it makes you
wonder what the what the motivation was
behind you for was it over the board
inspiration based on maybe some
psychological warfare going on as well
as no doubt ding Moran heard about the
bond interview but I've noticed that
about the Engler and sometimes he
unnecessarily sharpens positions without
saying there's a back-up plan or there
was some kind of logical foundation to
it and I've seen it more than once where
he takes a position that's just
perfectly normal were to 2780 players
would just make a draw in 10 moves and
he just blows it up pushes pawns makes
weaknesses and sometimes it goes in his
favor just because it's such a strong
player but sometimes you get these kind
of positions where you're wondering why
did you do this you know but I think
mainly it's just Hughes an extremely
fighting player he likes playing
complicated positions and feels
comfortable playing them in general so
he just goes so what gives him the most
complex situation over the board but
yeah I think it it already I think it's
safe to say it backfired to a degree the
question now is you know the ward degree
rooks even played in the meantime on
this board and I think now that and one
instruction we were having here after G
for Bishop 6 is where the black should
take on d3 and if n if it ends up with
white taking on g6 I think the answer is
just no right the answer is just no and
now that we haven't taken on d3 and why
do you take on g6 you can unpin just by
playing Queen d7 for instance because
Bishop takes f6 doesn't worry you in the
slightest and 27 with the intention of
playing 94 next move seems very very
logical here because if I don't think
you can even maybe a fourth all out 94
after that your position just starts
looking extremely ugly so it feels like
maybe white needs to take and then play
something like I don't know Queen d3
kingi 293 and just pretend that this is
solid enough to
do not collapse right but the black is
such a tempting move because I mean
depending on the circumstances even I
think c4 can be an idea sure
and but they taking on f6 is so
undesirable a lot but I mean out of the
you know the the two options that white
has here one one being the knight
lending only for and the other one
giving up this bishop I I'd honestly and
I like bishops I generally don't like
trading bishops for Knights I'm taking
on f6 here in a heartbeat honestly I
really don't like the idea of this night
being being only four because I I don't
quite see how we will ever chase it away
like the way the way the white pieces
are set up let's say we play you know a
move of some description how are we are
challenging challenging this piece just
be too weakening you know if you could
get a three in you would but how do you
remove the night from f3 normally in
this position and we looked at this
earlier when they were and expand it
with g4 we thought aggression follow it
with aggression the knight came also to
e5 maybe we consider the moves f4 yes
you leave weaknesses but you have all of
these aggressive plans back in the
position here but it was this move
Knight e2 that just completely puzzled
us because it doesn't feel like it
belongs with the energy that g4 gives in
the position and we don't get the Knight
to e5 you can see just in a couple of
moves it's black that's covering this
position only five the knight doesn't
have any really good squares to go to
and since you don't have any good
squares to go to you don't play f3 you
don't control you for and it seems like
the cogs are just not working together
in this position for Dingley right and
that's why we're thinking the black is
just a bit better and I have two good
Queen d7 looks just awesome because
Bishop takes f6 like the dark squares
are so so weakened yeah yeah I think
maybe I'm over selling Bishop takes f6 a
little bit but I honestly dislike the
position I have on my analysis board
quite quite badly for white as well I
just and as Alejandro was saying I I
don't necessarily even mine g4 all that
much but g4 followed up by 92 is just it
feels like we're playing two different
games
like we white is in two minds here
whether he wants to play an attacking
game or just just play play containing
containing ideas so yeah very much
likely ones position and so I'm sure
does doesn't live on and we do ever
create fifty-five yeah which we yeah
yeah we have this for a while yeah we've
seen that some time ago but I every
seeing the Ren really thought for a
while before playing ninety two the head
was where he thought for a long time and
it makes me wonder if he was really
thinking hard about playing and the main
idea ninety-five for a very long time
which was the first surprise that we had
because Bishop g4 we do know is the main
line of this position once you take with
the pawn on d5 the move Bishop g4 is the
main idea of countering White's setup in
this position
there are other ways of developing here
with the black pieces but backfire
Bishop g4 is the most plate move into
position Bingley Wren was surprised by
Bishop g4 thought for a really long time
I want to say was twenty-one or
twenty-two minutes on the move h3 Bishop
h5 kind of quickly played g4 and then
slowed down and decided after a long
thing to play ninety two so it
definitely feels like his mind is not in
one place in this position not really
sure where he wants to lead his army
towards and that kind of been decision
especially with the move as committal as
g4 can lead it in the real trouble and
in the current position I have to say
Queen d7 is something but pretty much
anything that Aronian does should be
enough to say blacks a bit better yeah I
think there is no horribly wrong choices
over the of the normal moves in this
position right likewise something like
this would be six mix and something like
in general you want this Bishop on the
b8h two diagonal so Bishop e6 makes some
sense Bishop a5 c7 which is something it
looks a bit artificial but you want this
this battery on on the diagonal and 27
after some thought because of this key
black has a number of options 27 is what
LaVon opts for and we have Maurice
Ashley from London with some thoughts on
this top
well I've been hanging out with the
British GM's the commentators Hodson and
and Lawrence Trent I am Lawrence Trent
in fact and all of your arguments are
coming back to the same story black is
fine in both games the night that MVL
had in this position finally has come
into the game but at the cost of
compromising his pawn structure somewhat
big arguments about this decision by
ding Lorraine to play the move g4 and
then following up with 92 which looks
inconsistent at best so looking like
black is doing well but then they
started talking about less sartorial
choices and said that Julian Jules
Julian Hudson said that he thinks that
level wears these clothes when he saw
the green shirt and the green shoes he
said Lev came for business this this was
his way of spurring himself on so that
he could win the game but Lawrence said
I completely disagree I think he wears
these horrible colours because he
doesn't want to go back to the hotel
room and look at himself so he has to
play hard chess and try to win and then
Jules countered with well you know I had
a friend who played chess who dressed
like this but he was caught a blind
maybe we should ask Levitt he's got some
colorblind issues alright all kinds of
craziness happening in this room over
here can't say that the British aren't
famous for their weights I want to say
that Laurence probably by this point
should know better and not offer his
sartorial advice to do anyone for for
fear of retribution but he just doesn't
he just doesn't learn I heard there's a
campaign tranfered yeah and also I very
much endorse you know this show engaging
in what I've been doing for four years
which is let's call it gently teasing
Laurence translates and I gotta say I
love the burgundy burgundy was like such
an underrated color and then the
lime-green hey he's trying something
he's definitely trying something but it
is that he is trying is is unclear to me
but there's definitely something going
on there yeah I may be Indian
what do you guys think I mean is this a
yay or a nay but actually I do have a
question there I'm gonna vote yay but I
got a question from the Twitter audience
from Craig who asks if Grisha asked you
to help him prepare for the candidates
what would you say
that's an easy and easy one for me to
answer because I feel very confident in
saying I will not be asked so it's it's
it's an easy one for me to cover I'd I'd
love to help but I feel the the
likelihood of me ever ever being asked
is is extremely low it's not because you
guys are too good friends just so I
think but by this point he feels that he
can find people who can actually help
him instead of somebody who will you
know like him a great deal yeah I got
short all myself short that's good but
that can be a bonus in some cases like
of course Alejandro very good friends of
Saviano but I can see that sometimes it
can also be but he's also a tremendous
analyst as opposed to and so on and so
forth yes tapper on our Twitter feed and
again the way to get in touch with us on
Twitter is to use the hashtag GCC finals
and if you want to get in touch with us
on the phone we just have that number
pop up and we can pop it up again for
you in just a second is that will also
be a good way to call us during the
classical portion although once we get
to rapid and blitz we won't be taking
phone calls anymore yeah that will be
the challenge to manage and the the
other game of the day the other game of
the David II the game between MBL and
magnus carlsen is proceeding sort of the
way we expected which should be 675 is
on the board and this is where we're
playing Finn b7 it's not the only move
in the position but it appears the most
logical you attack the pawn the cleanest
and a nice diagonal you can imagine
getting the bishop to d5 at some point
you know maybe white can sort of
stabilize by playing Knight a5 Queen b6
on something like
for with the idea of meeting room z8
with Lucy five but you're sort of
playing with fire here a little bit
because like if there's somehow
collapses or let's say 55 is strong in
this position followed by turn on queen
g6 and then some kind of a rook
activation you know who the end up you
could end up with a somewhat stuck
knight on e5
how are you defending the point if I
just attack it out of curiosity if
instead of Ruby area I would be eight
yeah I just missed that move yeah I was
very sort of focused on trying to take
the other one than the other one we can
actually defend where is this one but
this is just analysis of any factors
work to e5 but this hasn't played clean
270 in this is positional on the board
but we do have a phone call from Nepal
welcome to the show let us know your
name in your question yeah thank you I'm
some thoughts from Nepal I'm a big fan
of all of you guys I love what your
commentary it's so so so much tensile
Toulon here in the beginner player a lot
of lot of things a lot of data to
increase from watching you for watching
um injury so thank you thank you some of
the time do you think if you you're
going to be a woman only I mean you come
because you've been inclined to come
injury and sort of other things so what
your experience and I taught you to be
ready right equipment
that's a flattering question but
somewhat outdated I think I think by
this point
the likelihood of me becoming a world
champion and classical chess is of not
very high I could still you know I got
close to the podium in the rapid and
blitz last year but in classical chess I
think I've I don't rate my chances very
highly and that's not just my normal
mode of you know understanding myself
it's but but we do have the admittance
that that is your normal world number
eight in blitz you are playing in a few
weeks in the world with Championships
right yeah audience will be rooting for
you of course but in classical I felt
like I played three kind of the
tournaments in a row from 13 2013 to
2016 and I did feel like I maybe could
have had a better shot at qualifying for
a match and playing a match I wouldn't
have been a favorite in the match
against Magnus obviously but getting
there felt like a realistic goal did not
happen and honestly I'm not sort of I
will continue playing in qualification
events if I if I'm qualified for them
obviously but I don't really see myself
as a favourite there so I have a
question from the three candidates that
you played what did you feel was missing
that your skills you certainly put your
mark in the destiny sure no but in the
more you know more serious fashion in
London I felt like the Magnussen and
Vlad II was just playing a lot better
than me the one I felt I really had a
shot in was and yeah this game is about
to finish now so we can just favor watch
them and silence or should see playing
world champion yeah although I did I did
bid him I was like I kind of tried very
very hard not to let him play as much
more for the World Championship but
that's how it all worked out and yeah
now we will have some kind of way I mean
I wonder what I was going to say I
wonder if Magnus is white in this
position does he continue forever
because I okay - it's clear I like Roque
soon so why would you because let's just
show this on you we will watch them
shake I never will show it - will show
it on the board so my point is if not
for okay - if you play something like
rugby - root k-6 rugby 3 rock c6 you
either give up on c7 or you play rugby 7
and you wish you would have given up on
c7 because the position is so so passive
it's still of course a reasonably easy
draw at this level but this is a very
passive setup where black I mean I think
this position Magnus actually continues
for a while yeah but this is why he
played rock 8 so this is why he chose
very specifically to give up not the
pawn on e6 but the pawn on c7 and now
there's really nothing to play for
because the rook is not not behind you I
mean not on on a very poor square on b7
doing only one job of protecting the
pollen c7 is quite active and do you
know that the rules of the grand chest
were saved that in the classical games
you cannot offer draws so therefore they
will have to figure out a way to either
trade off all the pieces or more likely
just repeat the position with some work
Jack's they manage usually they find
repetitions they are they are
professionals and oh I mean one way of
yeah I was about to say just actually at
play h5 liquidate into a two against one
and and just make a draw this wage 5gh
or pitch 3 because the black king is
somewhat passive here this is like if
you allow white to get the pawn to h5
it's still a draw but like you start
feeling that there are some scenarios
where you might calculate but might be
forced to calculate some variations and
just playing h5 gh and walking h7 even
is what - chose their kings you - King
h6 famously this position is drawn even
if you lose the g7 pawn
although they're white of course is
perfectly entitled to to continue
forever and to continue asking questions
but with the pollen g7 still alive
it's about as absolutely drawn two
against one as they get and some draw
without the g7 phone and the area sex
fun that's what I mean that's what I
meant yeah even
if you lose what once white takes ggh
five if you pick up the porn on H five
you can lose both of yours and still
draw theoretically although people do
occasionally lose fnh against zero even
strong players occasionally get tired
basic I think the most favorable famous
one involved I think Romney pitching
Aronian in wieck one year and but that
was a very long time control because
wieck i think is seven hours and they
didn't get there by move thirty so at
some point you just get very tired and
you you run very low on time in the
final time control trying to defend yeah
don't play king edge six here that would
be actually don't touch the king that's
the king you're out but here we have of
course that wouldn't happen can you just
would have allowed working to checkmate
my was quite remarkably he is going for
an active plan of defense I think he
might actually go rotate 180 43 eight so
here and say please show me how you
proceed from there but yeah I mean we're
talking about this while we're waiting
for them to find a way to just change
everything off because this is they both
know it's a draw and they would have
shaken hands by this point that it's
just not allowed by the rules yeah and
now of course they're gonna have to
decide their magic suing this is a draw
in a the next couple of minutes they'll
be deciding this match and wrapping in
blitz tomorrow it's all gonna be decided
tomorrow and that's really exciting for
us of course in terms of tournament like
much intrigue you you don't really want
the classical to end in anybody's
victory because that excuse the much so
headed in in that players favor yeah
then they might have to over press and
the rapid portion it might just be
eliminated in that but that's also
exciting as well I wouldn't mind if we
had one of each one that was dying and
one that was decisive so we could see
the different flavor so it's it's we
have sort of conflicting emotions here
and I think in like in a way a
tremendously exciting very well played
classical draw is what
right or when each yeah yeah all one
lineage but after the first day that's
really longer no longer on the cards and
yeah Magnus actually apparently giving
it some serious thought even though
there's no no danger whatsoever here and
he's just like rugby three and that's uh
that's showing them just what he thinks
about this position
rugby three would be 5 and then King H
six and stuff starts disappearing off
the board and now I think that the big
like the principal question here is
there I think two schools of thought you
can just give give your stuff instantly
away or you can try liquidating into
some kind of a pawn ending to the H pawn
being your extra pawn and then give
stalemate and glad there's a school of
thought about these things mmm I'm glad
there's a school of thought about I'm
obviously you know this is somewhat
tongue-in-cheek but there are some
people who will actually you know make
sure they end the game with an extra
pawn and you know I've been better this
game I'm pressing in kind of a kind of a
statement a shout-out to mr. dodgy on
Twitter saying I thought it was clear
that Aronian was dressed as an avocado I
think this is excellent but I'm not
surprised because thought she generally
is excellent referring to Rania and
who's wearing burgundy or you could say
avocado pit cover and me know he's doing
he's doing like the entire upper cut or
yeah yeah not just one part of yeah he's
permitted he's very committed to doing
doing the avocado today a fight to the
death
chambers king i like the biggest trade
off all the pieces i think that's the
way to do it and they have a very well
played role is this match will continue
on to rapid and blitz and now we did
take a look at lavon's out for real
quick so we can see what act chess
problem mister dodgy was talking about
LaVon
in his avocado sister suit no I gotta
say though I feel like this is actually
a bit of a status symbol for LaVon
because he's been on the top of the
chess world for so many years and you
know colors like burgundy and lime green
they're not available in all seasons so
it shows that you know he's been doing
that like we know that no no no they
move on wears designer clothes so
something like lime green might only pop
up into the the lines like every 10
years so this means like he's a
successful man for many years and he's
got the lime green shirts and they're
gonna be jacketed he's a field of a
federal right now it's not his own but
is it in season he's a Tribune yeah I
think I think and here is the
combination although you don't really
see the perfect Burgundy in this bubble
you just see the shoes though which we
don't see in a normal shot yeah
beautiful livers livers an icon I mean
those shoes are definitely not cropping
up every season
I'm telling you out right now and
meanwhile his position is also good
dispersion is excellent yeah and
actually after the last move that
digging around played I'm a little
curious about them because he was
inviting this rookie for move they
weren't on purpose put the Queen on d3
you know remember that he took on g6 so
he didn't have to do that yeah let's go
back a little bit we will uh saw this
position after Roxy won and they won't
do play Queen d7 and ding appears to
agree with me that the knight has to be
traded off although I actually take your
point about the dark squares I I wonder
if that is better or worse than let's
say Kings you do by this point right I
still feel like an abuse game I would be
very tempted to take but having thought
about this for a while I suspect this
might not be all that good for white
takes and yeah he plays Queen d3 now and
I think the point about rookie for at
first I thought oh dear does live
actually intend to play after 93
something sugar 44 which of course he
isn't well we have interview so we'll we
will return to this in a bit Morris
Ashley is in London with Magnus Carlsen
we are with world champion Magnus
Carlsen after a draw with MVL Magnus
first of all before we get to the game
itself all your thoughts
after yesterday coming into today what
did you want to achieve I wanted to
surprise him a bit in the opening again
as you could so you could see yeah I was
in a decent state of mind wasn't
thrilled with the draw yesterday but I
thought the game had been interesting so
something with that and yeah today I
thought in general draw was okay but I
didn't mind playing and as the game went
on there wasn't much to do tell us where
the first interesting moment came for
you know so so be three sort of the safe
way to to play here and I think I got
very very easy play after Queen c6 and
he thought for for for a long time and
basically he his mindset here was that I
should try an eco license even though
his structure is better the night on a3
is it so bad that there isn't really
anything to hope for for him so after he
went c4 I think there wasn't there
wasn't that much to do at least after I
went to h6 then I had some hopes for for
Queen b7 here but I don't think it
actually does anything Queen c3 yeah he
has control so I decided just the first
ago you were you were hoping he might
push a little bit here this this
critical moment you said he thought for
a while everybody was really wondering
sorry here before he played c4 was
wondering what he might play was there
anything you saw that might have been
dangerous well he just felt like just it
was just too solid for you know I mean I
thought to be honest I thought about
this plan with rook C 1 naught b1 2 C 3
but then he's already lost some some
champion I think he definitely cannot
really look for
for an advantage there so think what you
did was was quite sensible and maybe
after a b3 that was that was the one
moment where I could have thought a
little bit longer but I think
realistically it's going to end up with
mass exchanges and then drawing me well
tomorrow is rapid and blitz your
thoughts about facing off against him
he's pretty fast player yeah you see
it's a very good reputable its player
obviously it's one of the reasons he's
made it here two years in a row so it's
kind of interesting to see all right
looking forward to it good luck tomorrow
thank you that should be a really fun
day I can't wait to see that match go
down yeah that should be a treat
tomorrow two exceptional players and a
short time controls at least six games
right yeah we'll play Italy six and then
you're right if there's a playoff will
get extra games and of course it will
all be determined by Armageddon if those
games are also split so that's that's
the way William Maurice with Maxine by
fear the groud yes it's French number
one and Maxine by Sheila Groff sir a
draw with the world champion might see
him again yesterday was a tough game
interesting fight did you put it behind
you to think about this Fargo today yeah
of course I mean the thing is I got
surprised and she opening and I couldn't
figure out what to do here because like
a year a year ago I wouldn't have maybe
been cautious but I remember you know
LaVon lost very badly against mamedyarov
and it gets sort of marshal
compensations and you know it's actually
very tough to play on the body if you
don't remember your analysis I was even
considering some foolish things like
this castle cd5 and then give up an
exchange but then I realized mean if
anyone's worse it's me so I decided to
to go the safe way
and yeah when she I wasn't up it was my
position my first plan was okie five but
enough to Bishop if I'm just much worse
already because of six is a sweat and
then there's lots of Queen moves but
after work yet in my night on these
fields just not getting in play so I
went for c4 and I still thought that was
like very slightly worse for instance if
f3 takes he goes Bishop e6 I might have
to go c5 then the good thing is my night
was coming back into place I thought I
should be holding this but I didn't
expect a free ride like a magnet it was
27 after which it's just returning our
Toto I mean I thought for a second about
90 streams and I noticed this except not
today
all right well - classical games both
draw on your thoughts about playing
against Magnus of course he is excellent
wrapping this player ya know it's gonna
be a tough fight tomorrow but I hope I
can I can play my Trump's because yeah
maybe I think it will be vital to maybe
not get out prepare like I did today so
I will need to to be ready for his
openings and then I I think it can it
can be a fair fight
one thought final thoughts about your
good friend Levon Aronian playing sting
we're in this position does not look
attractive for doing the ring your
thoughts about the chances for black
yeah I've just noticed that Nigeria does
little to nothing because I've simply
work yet and you cannot take this work
in general life I never think this is
much worse for white because this pawn
structure with f6g six of seven is not
ideal but at the same time this Bishop
is a good Trump so I give you we located
on c7 can already cause some problem if
you relocate black's knight to e6 it's
it's also huge some
yeah it's not gonna be easy life phone
for ding all right thanks for that
analysis well let your rest good luck
tomorrow thank you much
and here we have the current scores six
six Maxine ba she'll arrive at Magnus
Carlsen after - well played Rawls with
lots more chats between these two with a
Wizards tomorrow meanwhile lack of chess
left today for digging around and Levon
Aronian because that game is quite
interesting interesting more so for
Levon Aronian I think yes yet he's a lot
more excited about this and also look at
the clock forty forty minutes a hand on
the clock well or behind depending on
how you count these things 93 played by
biting not because as MVL mentions it
does anything it's very important that
you can just play okay actually not
there's gonna be three there's going to
be five I want to say 555 four yes I
want to say that this is not playable
for for the black side I also put up
just I cannot see sex I think so you're
saying what about you think of six I
think is still somewhat worse although
maybe it's an ad with the New York
fortunes so let's see what's going on
here because you're here I feel like
something like rookie form will just be
made with rookie for crime and once
again I'm being how heavily helped by
the bar indicating that the position is
dead lost for white I would have I think
I was holding fine rocky for but so
after pawn takes c6 rook three four hope
you wanted min takes h3 and a brute
force brute-force attack forcing the
Queen G too late nice variation yeah so
that poor not have six ends up doing
it's good yeah you you don't have Queen
g5 here although like even if I couldn't
take I think Bishop d6 may still have
been very strong I think even without
every six moment up winning in this
village that's even prettier a little
bit of a rare pattern isn't it yeah and
we do have another phone call from Marin
but welcome to the show yeah it's a
little Marilyn let us know your name and
your class
hi Jennifer and Peter Svidler I'm a fan
and I enjoyed the show greatly my
question is uh back in the nineteen I
think 1930s during the times of Jose
Raul kappa blanka the world champion
games he complained the game the chest
was being solved it was very crouched
and and he was complaining about a dead
draw and well if you fast forward to
today and if you were to say a 2,500
player who compete against the older
champions from those times they would
lose because of what has been discovered
nowadays so but what happens is that now
with computers and the database is being
so big and correspondence chess it seems
that we are again looking at that
problem so many games already in the
draw high play computer chess with some
of my friends and that I see how we end
up like killing or pruning entire
branches basically a branch of a
particular line we can no longer play
that line because it just leads to a
dead wrong so my question is in 10-15
years from now with engines people
keeping on getting even stronger and
longer and and the 15 happening with
hardware do you think we are where we
are solving check well that's a as
you've it's it's very good that you
phrase the question the way you did
because it's good to remember that the
whole discussion about just being solved
and just being a draw and you know the
the draw death of chess not the chances
that draw I think it is in Russian the
this discussion was always phrased as a
draw death of chess you're probably not
not doing this properly but anyway it's
it's very cyclically and it comes and
goes and copper spheres and in the 1930s
were somewhat unfounded and I think the
conversation didn't reappear for quite
some time after that and it's a lot more
based in reality right now because as
you correctly pointed out the computers
do do a great deal of of work solving
particular particular lines of opening
theory and especially forcing you know
tactical variations do get do get sold
but I think there are a few things to
consider here first of all it only
really concerns extreme top-level play I
think if you go down to even let's say
the results between twenty six fifty is
playing each other the drawing
percentage goes to very manageable
levels there will obviously be the draws
in games within players of similar
strength but it's it's nowhere near as
prevalent as people I think like to
think and secondly computer chess and
imp like let's say advanced chess or
straight-up computers playing each other
has very little relevance in terms of
practical play because even if you know
something is completely drawn you might
just decide to avoid those lines but if
you want to repeat computer preparation
in those lines it's it's almost always
unmanageable it's there's just too much
information so it all boils down to the
question of whether you consider
computers in general a threat to chess
by this point or a tool to use to become
better we've accepted computers are
stronger than us it's been very true for
decades now and
[Music]
we know we know it's a fact of life but
we also know that you don't you're not
gonna be able to use that knowledge in
practice because it's just memory
doesn't hold this much I mean in my
opinion I've been hearing about the draw
problem of chest since before I was a
grandmaster I mean I grew up already
with the idea that chest was going to be
solved in the next five years and that
has been something I've been hearing
forever and more than five years have
passed and nothing has really changed
in the sense that chess is still very
interesting we still get amazing games
computers help us but they are very very
very far from solving the game
especially it with have a theoretical
battles you still see exciting new ideas
just look at the game yesterday yes it
ended in a draw but it's not a problem
draw it's just a very cool interesting
game between Magnus Carlsen and Maxie my
share of the graph I kind of dismissed
this draw death ideas because they've
been around for so long and they've been
some doomsday kind of scenarios in which
that's it the computers have solved it
why do we play chess anymore and I just
don't see it in the practical games we
still have incredibly interesting chests
we still see brilliant victories so I
think that definitely the game has
evolved completely since kappa Blancas
time but it doesn't have any risk of
dying down do two draws anytime soon
well just yet but also I want to add
that I don't think I think the threat is
overstated but also there's been a
concerted effort in particularly in the
past couple of years to make a Fisher
endow a larger part of of the chess
calendar and to promote it you know much
more serious fashion than it has been
done for for a number of years ever
since let's say the minds tournaments
disappeared this random was very much on
the fringe is only really played online
if you if you wanted to play the game
and now there's there's a structure in
place which makes the strongest players
in the world participate so yep and
shout out to Wesley so yes
a world champion but Peter also right
here on the grand Chester we're doing
something at the contest draw that but I
didn't think sometimes understated you
know the rapid and blitz tournaments of
the world are becoming more and more
prestigious and I think that's a
reaction from both the audience and the
players that these players be placed so
well at the rapid time controls this is
just as prestigious as being great at
classical chess in many ways yeah and I
think that in general the the things
that are being done to the tournament
schedule to Ian tranches stories is very
much a front-runner in that respect
because this is a very prestigious
series of tournaments which highlights
all all time controls and allows for you
know a great expression of different
chess skills so like my answer would be
twofold first of all I don't think we
are necessarily you know at the brink of
extinction as a as a game but also
things that are currently being done to
make just livelier are quite efficient I
quite like what is being what is being
attempted and those two things combined
I think make make me feel you know quite
quite optimistic about games at least
short term short term future definitely
and maybe even a long term future well
speaking of the games let's go back to
chess see what's happened in the game
between Levon Aronian and dingle around
like what were the black pieces we
really like his position let's take a
look at the last few moves after the
move Knight g3 we were kind of expecting
the move rook a yet but the reason that
you can't take on e4 in this position
and take only four it's not because of
Queen b5 we did see this kind of runs
into ideas of context f3 d5 rookie four
and this checkmating ideas the game is
not quite over here you still have the
move rook c4 and the position is a bit
of a mess but even more accurate
according to the engines is to put the
Queen on c4 a very similar idea but
you're immediately covering the
fourth-ranked and in this case if you
take on f3 d5 you could be talking about
a great compensation for the black
pieces but you are sacrificing material
you will have to drop one of your minor
pieces you could immediately try to
regain the material like this but it's
going to lead
and to probably a slight white advantage
because this part on f3 is going to fall
so instead of that
LaVon had a couple of ways of playing
this position the move Queen e7 actually
retains the tension because in this case
after Knight takes e4 pawn takes e4 it
doesn't really matter where the Queen
goes and you attack my knight the queen
is already defending this Bishop so you
don't have any tactical resources here
in this position for white
you basically just resigned after I take
on f3 the two pieces combined way too
much for the lonesome rook instead of
that LaVon played the move rookie 7 and
I was wondering if you're gonna play
rook e7 why wouldn't you just play rook
e7 here I don't really think the night
was going anywhere else I think it
probably does land on g3 90% of the time
anyway so I'm not quite sure why if you
play rookie 4 time to the night to go to
g3 and then move the rook back to be 70
I'll have a suspicion maybe that he was
planning to go rock a8 and then he
realized it doesn't exactly work
tactically and Queen e7 just didn't
appeal to him for some reason that would
be my very likely and after the moves a3
Bishop d6 rook e1 it seems like at least
ding Lorraine is taking some tension of
the position taking a couple of rooks
off the board now
LaVon doesn't play rookie in and trade
even more pieces instead he plays the
move King g7 the rook is very obviously
going to the square h8 world will be
attacking opponent and there's also
something that's MBL mentioned which is
very very relevant here the light on c6
looks like a nice piece but if you
imagine that being on e6 yes that's
where it badly wants to be and this is
something that dingy Aaron would have to
pay great attention to and make sure
that he has a good reply to a potential
rerouting of that Knight towards the e6
square you do have the idea of just
placing light only - and saying you know
we have parity your knight is active -
passive but I'm still controlling all of
the entrance squares I don't think it's
gonna have much of a choice because this
is almost an estoppel idea yeah it's
very very difficult to find practive
ideas - to play against that you can
play King g2 and maybe hope to play
Queen b3 and start sort of just
tactically distracting like from getting
there but it feels like you know it's
been in particular with the King on g2 I
can just I can just go for it because
this is now even a check
it still it feels like live has maybe
had some more ambitious tries but this
is still far very far from equal how far
far yeah yeah it's a very nice position
for black it's obviously an improvement
for why that some pieces came off the
board and white now has the control of
one of the open files but you still very
much want to play g4g to here and
nobody's going to let you yeah yeah yeah
that's something we tell her to answer
hey but it sure the cloud so shout out
the no shout out shout out to you oh
that's more recent London who has some
comments
I think we have some talking to go back
tomorrow you know I wanted to I wanted
to say shout out to Grandmaster Sam
Shanklin with the book about bones not
going backwards giant steps to well you
know small steps to giant improvement
wanted to one of one of one of those yet
did we get any royalties out of this or
are we just doing this for free question
we got to negotiate that probably I'm
probably this is the wrong move order
you should probably ask the question
first and then and then the free
publicity but we're stupid like that or
this time what to do I do have to agree
that lavon's position is pretty nice but
I would still like to have those drugs
on the board and I really like the
bishop on before controlling this e1
diagonal and I was wondering after a
three I thought the bishop would which
is why I was about to ask you that exact
question why don't you prove why don't
you provoke before here yeah because
once you provoke before first of all the
bishop can retreat to be sexy instead of
d6 and that might make an argument for
d4 being a very strong weakness
especially there's nine or Neph three
having to stay in a position where it's
very uncomfortable the reason this night
is uncomfortability place is that this
barn f6 is doing a great job of
controlling it this allows me to move
the knight away if I wanted to without
fearing the knight jumping to e5 and any
points and now especially with this pawn
being under attack it feels even more
uncomfortable and the reason you want to
throw him before is that it gives black
more ideas c4 is a long-term weakness c3
might be attack I could throw in a5 at
some point depending on the
configuration releases so even the move
Queen a4 at some point might be just a
nice way to jump into the position I'm
also kind of curious on why he didn't at
least provoke the move b4 with the move
Bishop a5 yeah I was I was very curious
about that ambition b6 was played I
think quite quickly yeah almost attempt
oh yeah when I thought this was a very
legitimate position to to dwell on quite
quite seriously in particular with how
much time on the clock left has to so he
definitely could afford to spend like 10
minutes figuring out if he wants because
I think we should play five more or less
forces before you need to
start fighting for the fight if you just
lose the fight for the e-file after okay
eight like if you play King jutsu rue
ke8 before Bishop e6 you might never
play rook everyone in this position
because you just dropped the default oh
yeah the second chance might never come
to fight for the final move like b5 has
so many weaknesses attached to it he's
forced to move 3 6 e 6 looking at the f4
square or a5 looking at the c-4 square
yeah it just it just feels like I have
to take to call Bishop d6 and a mistake
it might end up being the correct choice
here but I was surprised Bishop a5 was
was not even a longer a longer thought
do you think it's a bit upset about
having to move the rook back because
that does happen once in a while you
miss something you try to make up by
playing a bit quickly getting that
confidence back because the move rookie
for rupees 7 was also bit illogical in
my opinion yeah it didn't occur to me
because I thought we are luring the
night away from it too but we actually
we're not luring it from anywhere we're
actually making it go to ask where it
needs to go to write any a rookie 7 like
the 4 I don't think is a move at all
because after previous experiences it
probably has to go although maybe there
is some argument for 92-93 but why are
we like this is a setup that black
actually wants yes where you might just
get made it yeah
this cannot be this is gonna possibly be
good so if you play rook e7 yeah and
then okay it appears if we are getting
the same position we got in the game but
I mean I was at a temple right yeah but
then should you stop a temple for for
nothing
yeah slightly unclear by left shows what
he did choose but he is still very very
comfortable yeah yeah but you know
that's that's the nature of it just
because he got a dice position and an
advantage against things around doesn't
mean he's gonna win the game right he
still has to play accurate moves and so
far it feels like his advantage has
reduced but he still has that big edge
in the clock as well yeah a very large
on the clock and still of like there can
be no doubt that look is block is in the
drivers sit here but it doesn't look as
scary as the right as it used to yeah
somewhere around movemove 60 and 70 and
I honest
I thought if if the trend continues by
move 25 fights position could become
like critical to indefensible no longer
feels feel like the feels like this
could be the case feels like this one
if black wins black wins a long game
yeah and a long game will probably will
have because black stop manages some of
the permanent kind you have this better
pawn structure the Bishop on d6 is
actually quite nice it's difficult for
the Knights to find any kind of anchor
square so you don't really see a path of
equality for a wide what you do see as
defense and long defense I'm very happy
you said that because I think this is a
very nice way of evaluating Morris
positions where is some worse positions
you think okay I am currently struggling
but I know exactly what I need to do for
the position to become actually equal
not a draw but equal i no longer will
have any problems here I don't think you
can name any sort of legitimate
realistic things that can happen here I
mean maybe if let's say rooks come off
and the knight gets transferred from g3
to e3 and black steel hasn't done
anything
then maybe black will find the card to
get the night from six to good squares
because he will be occupied protecting
the d5 square and so on but that is a
lot of yeah yeah and against the player
of Leafs caliber you just know this is
not going to happen nobody will give you
those those free Tempe and you you will
quite often draw this position but
you're extremely unlikely to equalize it
until the very last moves of the game
when forces are exhausted and Kings you
to play it we mentioned this move and
normally you just play a tempo because
your h3 Pollin is kind of hanging in
variations and you want to kind of tidy
up your structure and everything but the
fact that this is now a check I think
this is why doing thank for a bit before
playing it because you and we do have
Grandmaster Morris actually from London
yes guys this point that when when
Magnus was here before when he was being
interviewed about his game his very
first reaction when he came to the
screen was hey black is much better in
the other game
and he was surprised when he saw 11
actually play the move rook to e4 and
then we got into the interview because
he felt that the other positions that
that position was just good and you
didn't need to put this rook on this
compromise Square
now when Maxime had made this point
about the rook on e4 the tactics around
the square when he went into the
analysis room with the British GM's they
started delving into these lines and
they came up with variations similar to
the one that you mentioned alejandro and
then the question was asked what about
this move g4 Julian Hassan of course the
gentleman from the 80s and 90s he said
this kind of move g4 would never have
been played by Karpov and MBL's response
was hey that was 40 years ago chess is a
very different animal today it is but I
think in the in this particular case I
think any wish would have been would
have been correct in not playing this
move and not even considering it for
very long you do see a lot more
liberties being taken with the with the
king size structures these days you know
h2 h4 has been a move in pretty much
every single position where it's like a
legal move you can make and here's where
we stand guys we've got one draw between
Magnus Carlsen and maxeen by a share of
the grab with a pending game between
Sigma ran against Levon Aronian where
the bond has the advantage to started
off as an ouzo Indian theater and
surprisingly black had got a pretty you
know obvious advantage pretty early on
when dig around played 11 g4 I do have a
question that is you know peripherally
related because it deals with the d4
opening from John Hartman the did a
letter at US chess he asks about your
what he calls outstanding green folk
horse from chess plenty more and he
asked are there any recommendations that
you change if you redid the course today
don't say you do it on the names oh no
no I'm very far from a specialist on my
name is Owen we have an in-house
specialist on the names Oh in in the
chest 24 offices so I'm not touching I'm
not touching things that I can delegate
to delegate and that's harsh
but I mean Yan Yun knows the news oh and
I don't is what I'm trying to say but
yeah that probably would be some things
that I tweaked the thing I'm very proud
of in terms of that that cream-filled
series of videos is that at least when
they were recorded I definitely I stand
by everything like I I came pretty close
to showing a hundred percent of my own
repertory there were some sports where
my recommendations
slightly different from what I would do
myself in particular after the videos
were released because I didn't want
people to be able to you know a pinpoint
exactly what had the what they have to
prepare against me in in practical play
but in 2013 I I would be very happy to
stand behind every single recommendation
there have been some mistakes found I
think in some cases I mentioned them in
comments and obviously life has moved on
and there's definitely things I did not
mention in the videos which have been
shown seems to be very legitimate
questions that need to be answered so
the series would need to be expanded
quite significantly like I can name off
the top of my head some positions and
the Bishop III grünfeld which I just
failed to consider when I was recording
it should be three Queen d2 and there's
a lot of things going on there which
would need to be addressed quite in
serious detail but is there any fork in
the road like a the treatment to the
main line or the treatment first Bishop
f4 where you would just give a totally
different like fork as you probably like
notice not off the top of my head I
against Bishop III what I what I gave I
think is an extremely sharp line which I
still think holds but there's probably
safer ways to play that I've discovered
since artist fights you find soon since
Bishop III I remember there were two
lines which gave me the most trouble
when I was recording those videos and
one was b3 and the other one was third
f3 and those two I think occupied the
most of my analyzing time when I was
preparing the videos and there has been
some changes made and in my file since
but the general concept I think would
remain the same well thank you so much
Peter for that answer and to everybody
who's
chiming in using the hashtag GCC finals
we're gonna take a quick break as we
will stay tuned to this very tense
battle between Bing Lauren and Levon
Aronian
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
[Music]
is the sound of compassion
of open doors
[Music]
we're people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
[Music]
[Music]
founded in 1939 the University of
Missouri is steeped in tradition with
more than 30,000 students Mizzou is
known for its high academic standards
music program and athletic tradition
this fall another competitive team will
be added to the campus and its
long-standing tradition of excellence
I'm Kristin Carrillo the head coach of
Mizzou's chess team and we will compete
against the nation's top collegiate
programs and represent the Tigers all
around the country mezuzahs coming fall
2019
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the Grantchester finals in London and
when we last this game between ding
Moran and Levon Aronian we've had
several booths in sempeter but check out
where we stand in the tournament itself
we are in the second round of classical
chest
maxime and mangas already finished their
game so that for is six-six today's game
well prepared Magnus was ready to meet
Maxim's before yesterday's game though
was a real thriller so I encourage you
if you missed it somehow to review that
wild Sicilian but now what we have is a
steady advantage for LaVon but what's
happened in the last four moves in g2
let's briefly look at how we got from
from there to here after King G to LaVon
as expected plane IG 8 and ding Mets the
arrival of not only six with 92 96 and
now not even 92 a move which was not
immediately forced by events but I think
he maybe is dreaming of one day getting
it to the e3 square and also maybe even
you know in a larger part it just was
doing so little out of three that any
other square basically is better than
then they have three squares so 92
played yeah considering putting the
other night on e - they were so bad on
f3 that's that's kind of cute yeah after
my D it's something like 91 92 I guess
yeah yeah
although then I don't g3 feels it's just
such a such an unattractive combination
of mighty steeds that white has here
Nyjah kuruksetra quechua and laughs only
you're only a screen here deep in
thought because this is a very typical
situation where it seems like you've put
every piece on its optimal square you've
sort of extended without doing something
committal you've extended to the maximum
and now there is still no immediate
breakthrough and you need to find a way
to continue improving your position and
this is what love is I think mostly
to concentrate it on right now so what
are we looking at because we do find a
lot of our pieces are great 96 broken a
chain it's already putting pressure I
really you couldn't make some argument
that the bishops better host it on c7
perhaps because it allows Queen d6 or
because a bishop b6 you could even have
it all the way back to be aid but let's
say you make a couple of slightly more
improving moves and then what where
would you say black is going to try to
strike yeah you want to open something
on the Kings side and because I think
achieving much on the Queen side will be
extremely difficult there's maybe some
value to playing a 5-4 the intention of
playing a four sort of in preparation
for future end games it's not gonna do
anything right now
but if the Queen's ever come off it
could also become a weakness but it does
fix the white bones on the 3 and B 2
squares which is something to at least
consider when you you are the the owner
of the only bishop on the board I mean
so dykes dark-squared bishop but it's
you know it's a you spent to tempie to
achieve some you know very very
minuscule advantages in the future and
game it doesn't feel very realistic to
to do this what I would like to try is
to find some tactical justification to
push for six or five somewhere to start
opening things up on the Kings side but
I currently can see no way of doing it
efficiently because f5 gf5 I mean we can
take G if it doesn't lose a pawn because
obviously white does not want to take on
a5 and lose the Queen here with my
default check but what you've done by
gfg F is if you've you've riru into your
structure on the Kings side and you
still haven't created a single threat so
this doesn't really look like it's it's
something that's particularly advisable
and I was looking at ways to maybe play
a five and after GF move the knight
somewhere and you know hope to at some
point recapture with a piece but once
again though it doesn't really have good
squares to jump to so what would you do
after do you have just playing I don't
think we're playing a 5-4 mediately I
was also looking at something like 95
hoping to maybe provoke a four and now
after 96 I think they will
an improvement for black because I think
well then you do have to calculate it at
five if it works I think we go back but
imagine if I pitch for them yeah yeah I
was going to say I just go back to G
five here and I'm quite happy but after
H 4 it needs to continue running
so yeah g 5 and it also has the drawback
of not really creating a threat we've
played this move we don't really want
anything anyway
well maybe not these three users threat
yeah I'm not sure if it's right or not
because I don't see the check yeah it's
a horrible move don't make a move like
this but just just the best just the
past I guess the only move here is oh
Jesus
we take like us to take with the night I
guess and we have ideas of a 5 or 4 as
one yeah one idea the tonight's first
but rook but with this weekend King and
you also have a pawn to do I don't know
if we could enough three was for stoic
but it does it does give up a third one
on d4 which I thought that were in here
are just way to meet boss yeah I think
that's that's quite quite bad for white
but a four is a strong threat I don't
know like I didn't like playing a three
at all like a three Queen g5 might just
be horrible I think we're finished so
just picks up picks up at this and he
goes love ends up with the move we did
not really mention but it's also sort of
quite thematic locate for okay oh I do
wonder what the point that's after
Knight f3 yeah because he does have to
go back right yeah well yeah well just
wants he's repeating but of course sting
Moranis him noses visions not smooth so
you've seen it's right back to d2 yeah
but I do not think that love is gonna
follow suit with row gauge for live did
complain about not feeling at his best
yesterday that's like possible this is
I'm Michael yeah yeah yeah left left
feeling fine we'll never ever stop
playing in this position I feel like you
you you run zero risks and you can
continue finding chapter you know tries
to improve but yeah if he continues
feeling somewhat under
whether he could maybe repeat and take
another day so to get Benin to get back
into proper fighting shape but it would
be a bit of a pity here if he is feeling
well and he's just doing that to tease
them around I kind of liked it because
it's that a little bit of like a
psychological maybe get his hopes up
that he doesn't have to keep fighting
and then say like Nassau but we're in
this yeah but oh there it is work age
fourteen another time and I think that's
going to be because the thing is after
okay changing can claim you can claim
and there is no move but work a shade
because otherwise you are actually
worsening your position yeah pretty much
have it the game has been drawn as we
will find out LaRon aronia explanation
for that although it could it looks like
he's analyzing with things around there
and potentially saw some kind of plan
that he doesn't like digging around on
the other hand I think it's more that he
is complaining that he's kind of he said
he's got more in this game it's it's
very very yeah true that somewhere on
move seventeenth his Vantage was larger
and he is quite upset at having maybe
slightly missed the boat with some some
of his early decisions I didn't really
think rookie force one of the things is
gonna be regretting because I think he
played rookie for exactly what the same
way that Maxine had originally putting
the work on he ate and then notice wait
a second is not actually playable and
perhaps at that point you thought okay
maybe I'm better but let's just take a
rest go tomorrow into the rapid and
blitz and yeah I agree with whoever said
that it was amid perhaps a little
rattling also that you play tricky for
and he had to retreat it yeah I could
have thrown him off his game a little
bit psychologically but this once again
it's also a bit of a symptom of him not
being at his at his best because he is
experienced enough to normally be able
to refocus and not let let that misstep
throw him off that much but it felt like
he was very much in control up to that
point and after he played rookie four
and after ninety three had to go back he
he felt like he no longer believed that
he is that much better and will
in the game and this is what it came
down to guys two draws in the classical
in both games and both matches that is
which means that it's all gonna be
determine tomorrow in a rapid and bliss
4.3 traffic game to a point for each
blitz game we're gonna start off with
two graphic games and we're gonna go in
for the four blitz games and finally
there will be playoffs if needed I think
there's a very high chance so we'll have
at least one playoff because these guys
are so evenly matched and the way the
point scoring system mate works it's
certainly possible it's yeah it's
definitely on the table six games is is
quite a lot of chess to be played and
with the rapid games being being
weighted more than the Blitz games if
somebody wins the rapid the rapid
portion he is obviously once again a
large favorite for the whole thing but
we could definitely have playoffs in at
least one of one of the matches but we
are guaranteed twelve games of chess
tomorrow which is something to look
forward to and we have Maurice with ping
rain
number three player Chinese superstar
ding Lorraine after a draw in this first
game in the second game against Levon
Aronian talked to us a bit pleased about
the opening itself especially this
decision you made right here after he
took on d5 what did you feel about the
position here I thought I was writing
better after Bishop g4 I don't know how
to continue and I think my player was
very own nature and very bad it turned
out to be very bad what exactly where
what was it at this moment it looked
like g4 was a very controversial move I
don't know how to continue I was very
bad chief you 51555 take take 97 it's
normal position you say it's a normal
position is it did you feel this was bad
for you or just a regular setup I don't
know how how I can deal with this pin
thing and that made you decide to
voidable h g4 instead when this happened
in the trade what were your thoughts
after this position occurred were you
feeling worse at some point like our how
soon were you feeling like you might
have any trouble after hit play look it
I missed idea Bishop b4 here if I
continue with that therefore he can play
these people
I miss this prime mantich problem Bishop
e7 and the bishop very good plays on e4
and since I cannot take but if I don't
take the absurd
in trouble so here I realized I would
worse okay and after this I think the
critical point came about here Queens
ad3 the move rookie for how many he you
want to play group he ate but he missed
Quincy for here we take in d5 but maybe
he can still play Bishop d6 I was not
sure about about this night the threat
of attacking it looks like strong
position for black here were you
surprised when he brought his room back
to East seven-year yeah I'm very worried
about group 8 after exchange of the peer
groups
my position is also words but know that
that that take us to the end then as
well right here when evil rock h1 what
was your evaluation of this position
when you feel better in many way to
continue I don't know why he didn't play
he's his he said he feels not good good
so you felt definitely you should be
flying some more moves here yeah so it's
a very bad play the game all right well
a bit of a I guess according to you a
bit of a lucky result you thought about
going into the rapid endless tomorrow
your chances you seemed feel nothing his
best physical shape but I'm not in my
best shape what does that leave for
tomorrow alright well we'll give you a
chance to do that and good luck Wow big
member I'm trying to come sorry ding the
Ren trying to compete with you Peter for
the modesty or it's the humility it's a
really fabulous combination of you know
extremely soft spoken in the way he
speaks but also those were some harsh
opinions including about his own play
and it's it's such a such a nice
combination you know very very soft
voice you know seemingly downcast but he
doesn't he doesn't really mean swords
anymore I think we're gonna see more and
more great interviews from big morale
I really enjoyed that and a lot of times
there he used the word a normal position
and I think he was very biased at this
point because he felt he was better and
a lot of times when I analyze with
Chinese players they use this phrase
normal position what they mean to say
sometimes is what we consider equal
position and what he didn't want is an
equal position after Bishop g4 h3 Bishop
h5 and this idea that Bishop g5 you can
take on c3 he basically felt he was
better and should be playing for more
and it almost backfired immediately when
he played g4 Bishop e6 and just started
looking at a couple of lines and the
psychological idea that you are better
because he takes t5 is not the main line
and then you have to figure it out over
the board
I think caused him to be overzealous in
this position and tomorrow we've been
mentioning we've got these wrapping and
blitz games 4.3 traffic game 2.3 splits
game the magic number that you need to
get is even
points that will get you into that final
match for 150 K and the grand chest Tour
champion 9 points because I don't think
you can score I don't know how true or
more than eight points laughs enough you
need because you get one point she's
strong and that was yeah that means that
if you loser out the game you have to
get three one in the blitz just two
three one meeting six two just to be
cool that is really tough
I mean arguably that's even harder than
the order we've been talking about for
classical to reverse a loss in a rapid
you very tough you always feel like
there's there's there's a chance to go
in a bit of a roll in in blitz and
there's definitely blitz allows for more
liberties like if you've if you're in a
must-win situation in blitz with black
it feels like you can really play some
incredibly dubious stuff and just you
know keep pieces on the board and
eventually you both will go down to one
minute and then things will start
happening so I don't think anybody is
completely out of it if they lose the
four to is a fortune 16:06
6-2 6-2 in rap you know my brain is
doing a remedy it's tough loads we
actually went clear you have to just
dominate the bus you need to get three
and a half to avoid the playoff so the
rapid there's gonna be so much at stake
in the rapid and it will take you know
monumental comeback if somebody loses in
the rapid here's what's at stake in the
rapid we've got two games worth four
points each there's a gate 25 at the
ten-second delay and then we move on to
blitz game five with three seconds later
there's that's what it is
and then the win for that is worth two
points each
and I want to say that one of the
biggest challenges perhaps tomorrow will
be maybe that Ferriss Blitz game because
25 was 10 seconds delay is a by today's
standards it's slow rapid like the world
the world record in Leeds is 15 plus 10
so this is almost about it's about as
slow as a rapid game gets these days and
then you play two of those you get used
to a certain rhythm you get used to a
feeling that you have you have time to
think you have you have some control
over how you spend your time and you
instantly I mean there will be obviously
break not you don't see the next second
and playability game but there should
still be a little bit of a lag in your
in your head between what you just had
on your clock in rapid and and the five
plus three which is it's also I mean
it's a reasonably slow pls game compared
to some other time controls but it's
still it's still blades although I do
find it a bit tricky because it's not a
pure 5 plus 3 it is a 5 with 3 second
increments so plus 3 usually delay so
anyway yeah 5 plus 3 usually indicating
increment and I think especially when
you transition as you were mentioning
from a slow rapid gaming to a blitz
sometimes you start a little bit slow
you're kind of used to the fact that you
can spend a little bit of time in the
opening but once you realize you have
two minutes left and there is no time
being added a little bit of panic starts
setting in yeah it is really difficult
I've noticed for these players for some
of them in particular when you get into
an end game and you have to reach your
pieces from one side of the board to the
other sometimes like it physically it's
difficult to make it into three seconds
especially if there's a moment of
hesitation and we see sometimes people
actually fly because of that yeah and I
think five three delay is a harsher time
control by far than 5+3 the way the way
we used to or used to think of it with
increment and yep once again I
understand that the point has already
been made but it will be an interesting
transition and in particular maybe the
first one or the first two please games
after you've just finished playing rapid
because I remember you know in the old
days
in the knockout events he would play all
three time controls in one day before
they designated as a separate day for
players in World Cups you would actually
play a classical game and if you match
ended 1-1 you would then proceed to play
rapid and then faster up in and then
blitz on the same day if you continue
making one month and that was just
barely manageable let's say for me I
remember I had great trouble adjusting
from classical to corrupt it on the same
day it's it's it's a problem that we've
all encountered and people you know
these are four extremely experienced you
know grizzled tournament veterans very
young people but still still grizzled
veterans nonetheless and they they will
not be new to the problem but the
problem does exist yeah it'll be great
to see how they handle you no doubt as
we get faster and faster and let's say
because it our brackets get so far
everybody's bracket is looking flawless
nobody's lost the game after all this is
my bracket I went with Magnus Carlsen to
be the champion over dinner end and the
finals and then I took Maxime baggier
the grab in the third-place match and
finally we have your brackets but mines
get away well I agree with you with mvl
on third place but I think they learned
some great shape and I especially like
that dominance he had on the Blitz games
in India against Magnus Carlsen so I
think it'll go down to the wire but
things gonna thicken in a tie-break yeah
and I think in Velen third is of like it
seems to be almost I think maybe Maurice
hasn't been fourth yes
so that's he almost got a clean sweep in
their fight yeah and as everybody speak
for third but Maurice going against the
grain your pick Magnus to win and this
is maurices bracket it's you also big
thing Lauren has the chance but he does
differ from Alejandro's racquet slightly
and though you picks Levon to get a nod
over MDL
so some interesting brackets it's
possible that we'll all lose
we used to figure I deserve a bonus for
picking the champ and then different
point systems but mule Ohio we have
Grandmaster Maurice Isley in London with
his final thoughts well the good news is
only one of us will win whoever that is
or we all lose if somebody blows up our
brackets right away this tussle between
nvl and magnus the M&M boys it looks as
though it's just going to go down to the
wire both players are playing well what
to do to just show that he's the
dominant player here so I think
literally anything could happen tomorrow
although it's still the edge to Magnus
in my opinion and the other in the other
brackets you would think the way ding
lorraine is playing is just not in great
form but Levon does look under the
weather he's said it before he didn't
come to the interview today either
it just looks as though he's not all the
way there but that said you know maybe
there's some good doctors medicine can
fix everything and then he'll be all
right with the world again tomorrow so
we'll see what kind of energy he brings
in any case it should be incredibly
exciting lots of rapid lots of blitz
that's what we live for should be all
the way down to the wire and we'll be
calling all the action here live from
London Thank You Maurice I can't wait
for the rapid and bliss myself for a
theatre and we have Grandmaster
Alejandro Ramirez with his final dog
there's a lot of things that go into
playing a great game of chess and for
aronia and one key factor was missing he
just didn't feel physically well I know
that if he was on a good day he would
have grabbed this position and tortured
no matter who he was playing against but
it's gonna go down to the rapid and
blitz tomorrow I'm personally excited to
see what we're gonna have because all of
our brackets can just blow up if Maxine
Brixton's a game only one rapid victory
so they take the put Magnus against the
ropes and we'll see if that happens
tomorrow will be a fun day roll up your
sleeves as we are getting faster and
faster tomorrow theater yeah plenty of
action some
and today we've had a bit of a dry day
in terms of in terms of the classical
games we've seen but not possible not
possible tomorrow tomorrow there will be
blood that's right love to see it and we
love to see you thanks everybody for
joining us and we will check you same
time same place tomorrow that's four
o'clock in London come ten minutes early
for our pregame show and that is 9:50
here in the studio in st. Louis the
capital of chess in America
[Music]